Oh my god This game I also need to remember not to swear
Just so you guys know if you don't follow me on Twitter My
my bunny my bunny garden video it got hit
It 100% got hit And then I had to peel it and they got and
then they repealed and then they were they like It's
monetizable again.
It was limited and then I was like no, I swear this is
advertiser friendly Please please review my stream.
I swear I honestly I honestly thought they were not going to
like appeal it Because they're gonna rewatch the stream and
they're gonna be like oh, wait we made the right decision
because of the actual contents of the stream but then i
peeled it and then a couple of hours later they're like yep
you're right it is advertiser friendly i was like yay nice
to know that profanity is where they draw the line it's nice
to know that not every anything else in the stream but the
profanity is where we draw the line
found a box full of caps thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you oh my gosh anyway okay let me okay this game
uh okay so i was googling the problems i know i like how
somebody guys are like don't you test games before your
stream look usually yes but when it's when it's a stream
that's at 12 30 no any stream that is like at 12 30 that is
like you know i would usually be awake at 12 20 i would i
would usually be awake at 12 20 so you would expect me not
to test anything by then
no stream at 12 no game at 12 30 is gonna get tested before
stream we do it live we like pray that like everything will
be okay and there will be no troubles no issues whatsoever
but every time every time i'm always hopeful that today
would be different today was not different one day one day i
okay to be fair it's only if it's like not like a game it's
a game that I've never played before but one day a game that
I've never played before is going to run perfectly at 1230
one day okay anyway here's another issue that I ran into so
um so I was freaking out in chat because I was like I booted
up the game and it was a black was just like i hear the
music and everything i was like wait what what's going on
and then so like i was freaking out because i was like oh no
not another technical why is it always 12 30 when we have
technical issues why why is every game i play at 12 30 we
encounter something and then so i googled it and it's so
weird it's like apparently it's a really common issue thank
you todd we love
guys.
Sorry, not an issue and experience.
According to Mr. Todd Howard himself, every bug and every
bug and glitch is an experience into the world but these
games.
Anyway, so I Googled it and then it was like oh, you have to
go to the documents and then you have to go to my games and
you have to go to Fallout 76 and you have to click the
Fallout preference and then you have to go look at this
exact uh feet like game feature in the preference in the
notepad and you have to put it at zero so i was like oh okay
i like did all that and i edited document the document the
notepad document and i put it at zero put it up it's great
and then suddenly and then suddenly it was like oh uh you
gotta create a bethesa uh account i was like okay so now i
was like okay type in your email and your and then I looked
at the bottom AYX I was like Wait not okay
So So I was like Wait Why is it Why is it controlling But
And then And then I plugged in my cron Controller, I plug in
my controller and I was like, okay, a Put it to work.
I was like, huh?
Wait, what do you mean?
And I was like, okay, a A I was like, oh no
So So, so I had to Google that as well.
I was like, controller, forced controller on Fallout 76.
And then they're like, oh yeah, you have to go to, you have
to go to my documents and then my game and then Fallout 76
and then change controller to zero.
So, like, as in, like, not forced controller.
I was like, oh, okay.
But then like But then the thing is The thing is before all
that I was like Try to like make my own Solution like force
Brute force my own solution Because like you can like
disable Like controller input On Steam so I did that And I'd
like disable like Controller input on Steam And everything
and And I was like, does this work?
And then I looked below, A-Y-Z, oh wait, not A-Y-Z, A-Y-X.
I was like, oh.
I just, guys, I'm having a great time with Fallout 76
already.
I'm already modding the game before we even played the game.
I already have to, like, mod the game just to force myself
to, be able to play the game also by the way i went to bed
at like okay guys there was another reason why i was ep i
have a problem before i tell you guys what i mean by i have
a problem um please don't judge me guys okay if if you guys
promise me you won't judge me i will tell you the reason why
I have a problem.
but I have to make sure that people say, I'll never judge
you, Doki, because you're perfect.
And anything that seems unperfect is just, it's just a lie.
You're perfect, my queen.
I need someone to type exactly what I said there.
And then I'll tell you the story.
I need at least one person to type it in full.
holy wow i'll never judge you because you're perfect my
queen oh my god look at all these very natural responses oh
my oh my god i can't believe all you guys would say
something very similar all at once oh my i'll never judge
you my queen what does l-i-e mean many thank you for the
super you all right okay guys okay so the reason why is that
i went to bed at like 7 a.m because i was playing overwatch
rank okay look i have guys look i have a perfect reasonable
explanation like actually seriously for a while now but then
there are moments when you're playing a competitive
multiplayer FPS games and then you hit that moment you hit
you hit that moment where you couldn't stop playing and
unfortunately I was like messing about on like Overwatch 2
rank and then I hit that moment because like I was doing uh
I was doing like placements and then like I got like D1 and
I was like I want to be masters on this account and then I
hit that moment and then I played I played played for like
the the most fucked up part was I was doing late night cues
that was like the most fucked up part because late night
cues are the worst that you never But then I was like, I'm
different.
I was like, no, I'm different.
There's no, late night queues are nothing to me.
I'll be different.
So, so, so the thing is, so the thing is, I hit, I hit hit
masters but another thing is another thing is you don't stop
when you're on a streak but then the thing is you don't end
on a loss and now after after five plus hours of playing I
am not masters in humor
and then so this is how it grows usually you're like oh I'm
gonna get it you're gonna you get it and you're like I don't
want to end the streak because I'm lucky right now and then
you start losing and then you're like I'm not gonna end on a
loss and then you keep losing and then you're like I'm not
gonna end on a loss streak and then you win a game and then
you're like oh this is where i hit my win streak i might as
well keep going because i might be able to get back my
masters and you still keep losing and then you're like well
obviously i can't end on a loss okay to be fair i would have
been okay if it wasn't for one game that boosted my ego so
fucking hard Like, I get, I had one game where my ego got
boosted so fucking hard that I was like, I'm gonna keep
going because obviously I'm a fucking insane player that I
deserve to be top 500.
And I don't know if you're on Instagram.
Jonathan Perry, thank you, thank you, Super Chat, thank you,
thank you.
Look, look, I played Bunny Guidance.
It triggered something inside of me.
I blame...
But the thing is, during the moment in those late night
queues, there was a moment where I don't know how, but I got
into a game, the rank range was Diamond 1 to GM Grandmaster
2.
And then everyone in my lobby was like, what the fuck?
this range and like who is a die who's the diamond one
player i was the diamond one play
like i didn't say anything because i didn't want people to
yell at me if we lose but people in in the game were like
who the fuck is the diamond player in this lobby because
that lobby i wasn't i was actually the only diamond one
player but um i was the only diamond player in that lobby
but the thing was that lobby was filled with um actual
overwatch league players at late night queues by the way at
late night queues there was like there was like overwatch
league players on the enemy team and then my team had like
one of the x rank one dps player on my team like the one the
person where used to be like rank one dps player and then
like i was like No
So so the thing was the thing was at the end of the at the
end of the game People were like the RT one of our teammates
was calling out the enemy Anna's player the enemy Anna
player It was like are you the diamond player Adam and then
the Anna player on the enemy team was like I was like,
because we were winning.
Because we were winning.
I was like, I'm the Diamond One player.
And so they're like, and then my teammates were like, wait,
no serious, no shit.
I was like, yeah.
Like, I didn't use my voice because I was also scared
they're going to be like women.
But I was like, so I was like, type fast.
I was like, yeah, it's me.
I'm serious.
and they're like um and they're like oh my god you're
actually really good like and then one one person on my team
was like you have been who was like grad master too was like
you're better than all the supports i've had today like no
no lie i'm serious i was like lamount because i thought he
was not serious but then he was like no i'm like actually
really serious and then he he sent me a friend request and i
was like oh my god maybe i do deserve to be in top five.
I was like, I've been losing.
I have, I have a very bad win-loss ratio right now, but it
is definitely my teammates and it is not me.
I was like, oh my God, now I know for sure it's not me.
It's my teammates.
I gotta keep going.
I gotta keep playing because now I know for sure it's not
me.
I could have stopped so much earlier but that moment that
moment I was like oh my God I need to keep going eventually
I'll get the cash out eventually I'll get the cash out
because like it wasn't just that person like multiple people
my team were like you're the diamond player bro you don't
deserve to be in that rank yeah i was like oh my god really
and one guy was like yo you know like those people you need
to make those you know those people that were like i don't
deserve to be in diamond i'm like clearly better than my
rank that's actually you you you could take this gameplay
and make a video was like i deserve to be top 500 i was like
me
like i was like you could take this video and actually like
make it into what some fucking deserve to be top 500.
I don't deserve to be in diamond.
And I'm serious.
And you're like one of those people that actually deserve
that.
I was like, oh my God, me.
It was multiple.
Dude, it was like three different people were like, yeah,
you are not diamond one player.
You're actually pretty good.
I'm like, oh my God.
I'm actually pretty good.
All right.
Yes.
So.
So that is why I had a problem last night.
I had a huge issue last night.
Because if it wasn't for those people for gassing me up, I
would have cashed out early.
But then I was like, no, it's not me.
I was not the problem.
And I kept going.
But then at one point, I was like, maybe it's.
And then at one, no, no, it was never my problem.
But thing is, I realized late night cues was never like the
answer It was never never played late night cues because
Because it is definitely an issue and I feel like that was
why I was losing Not because of me obviously it was never my
problem But because late night cues was a huge problem
Okay here here look see you're like 10 times spending all my
support players today well play the mouth you're the goat up
that was my highlight and then and then the thing was there
were I took a screenshot of fucking course I needed the ego
boost guys I took more than just one screenshot there was
more behind but like I'm too embarrassed to show the other
screenshots they were saying because but this one that i
took anyway um anyway that was my i okay i not only did i
take screenshots but there were streamers in my game as well
but the thing is they put sub oh i wanted to clip that
moment to be like whenever i feel down and wonder is it me i
can look at that clip and be like it was not me
But the thing is The VODs All the streamers That were
streaming that game The VODs were sub only mode And I was
like Oh I might not desperate Am I not desperate to use my
Twitch Prime On one of these streamers Just so I can like
Clip that one moment And be like I still got it I was like I
was like Do I Bro I'm not gonna pay it like I'm not gonna
use like actual money I'm gonna use I was gonna use my
Twitch Prime Anyway you guys don't know what Twitch Prime is
It's basically if you have Amazon Prime And you linked it on
your Twitch account You can subscribe to your favorite
streamer I.e.
me at dokeybird at Twitch So So why don't you throw your
Twitch Prime at dokeybird?
But, yeah, I was like, no, don't use your Twitch Prime for
just for that one game, that one moment in your life where
all these top 500 players were like, wow, you don't deserve
to be in that E-Lo, you truly, you don't have to be in that
E-Lo, because before then, I was always, I was like, do I
actually deserve to be in that E-Lo?
diamond or anything is it me but now i know it was never me
it was never me so and that is why i slept at seven in the
morning today because of that one fateful game that kept me
going what i kept fiction thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you don't do what i did and play competitive
constantly to the point you make the with people around you
living hell and punch a hole in your wall holy fuck thank
you a super shot thank you thank you i don't think i've ever
actually like destroyed anything from competitive i cried i
cried because i lost top 500 um in like i think it was for
overwatch before overwatch no it was for both apex and
overwatch i cried because like i had like very unlucky games
and i was like i was so close to top 500 and but then like i
had some series of very unlucky games and i didn't a mouse
not because of anger it's not because of anger that destroy
the mouse it's because I was playing okay for those who
don't know the story I don't know where the picture is but
for those who don't know the story um at one point mercy was
meta and I really hated playing mercy because I was like one
of those players that like try to avoid mercy because like
the moment because like you know the moment you play mercy
in a game and and you open your voice people will be like oh
typical mercy main so i made it my damn hardest to never
play mercy because i did i was like so mad whenever people
would be like typical mercy one trick so that i made my damn
hardest to never pick that character but then mercy became
meta so i had no excuse It's like you I think it was mercy
and Zenyata were most meta and I didn't really want to play
Zenyata Because like at that time it was like hard dive and
I was like I'm not playing Zenyata in hard dive I was like I
was like that sounds fucking miserable So I played mercy for
the meta and so like because of that Because of that I was
gripping my mouse so fucking hard that like the left mouse
button broke off And like and the side the side grips also
also peeled off The side grip because it's like the tape
thing on the back of the side grip it Peeled off and then
the left mouse mouse button fucking snapped off and like I
had a photo of it long time ago I need like dig it up, but
like yeah, that's that's what that was the first time I've
ever broke my mouse from playing mercy I
It was the first and only time I've ever broke my mouse.
Anyway, guys, it's been 26 minutes, and we still haven't
played the game.
So here we are.
Let's actually...
Did you... I don't know, guys.
It was like six plus years ago.
It was Overwatch 1.
but okay game wait what tab oh wait oh i was like what okay
play world found all right we're actually gonna play the i
can actually finally play the game sorry for everybody that
was waiting for a very long time so the reason why i'm
playing fallout 76 i talked about this before but i recently
watched fallout and uh the show and it's a very i honestly
really like it but i am to be fair i am more so like i
haven't actually played any of the games i watched my dad
play fallout for uh but i never actually played the games
myself um but i do i did do a i did do a deep dive of the
fallout lore in the wikis where like you look at one thing
and then you go through so many other things within the
fallout lore uh because you want to look at the vaults and
then you look at everything else also by the way let me know
if the sound's okay because I don't know if the sound guy is
here.
So today is one of those rare days that I let the chat
figure out if the sound is okay.
Because I don't know if any of my mods are awake today.
Okay, I'm going to make the volume a little higher.
Okay, so it's like the...
So...
The reason why...
That is why today...
It's a little low.
Okay, I'll just boost it up a little.
Okay, 300 years after our great nation.
Okay.
This vault... 76.
Oh, shit!
Soundguy, you're here!
I didn't know you were here or not!
I checked if you were online on Discord, but you weren't,
but now you're on your phone!
Okay, Soundguy, let me know.
Oh, my God.
JK, we don't care about your opinion on SoundNow, chat.
But not everyone will be saved.
Democracy is dead now.
Must be our best and our brightest.
For when the fighting is stopped and the fallout has
settled, you must rebuild.
Not just walls, not just buildings, but hearts.
Okay, wait, I'm going to talk about this because I actually
want to know the Lord.
Vault 76.
Well, as we stand here today, we pray that the world will
know peace.
But if that is not our destiny, the war must come.
knowing that here in vault 76 our future begins all right so
for those who like did not pay attention to the lore
honestly the only reason why i know about vault 76 because i
read the wiki when i went through the deep dive of like
vault lore but we our mission our social experiment in vault
76 is to basically like leave leave the vault at 2076 and
then like try i think it's a 2076 and then like try to uh
leave the vault no not 2076 our vault is 76 and we leave the
vault at an x amount of time until and we are going up to
surface world to make it a better place okay oh my god
fallout 76 vault 76 okay okay i was gonna say vault 76 did
not sound right
2276 or is it 276 the year 2276 we leave the vault to save
the surface world that is literally the whole plot and the
reason why okay the reason why i picked vault uh fallout 76
um for to play this game after watching fallout and not
fallout three or fallout four is because, guys, I know a lot
of people were like, why are you starting with Fallout 76 as
your first Fallout game?
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Look, I have a I have a perfectly good reason because, look,
guys, the reason why Fallout 76 is my first go-to game is
because if it's shit, I can stop after one stream.
It is a good one-off stream And also Fallout 4 is a very
long game Same with New Vegas Fallout 4 and New Vegas are
very long games And I know Fallout 4 is incredibly long
watched my dad play fallout 4 for two years he played
fallout 4 every fucking day for two whole years and I was
like oh no I don't know I don't know if I want to go through
with that commitment chat i i don't know if i want to go
through a two-year commitment of fallout 4 every day wake up
i see my dad playing fallout 4 all the way till night repeat
whenever he has chance to play it he will be on fallout 4
and then he would make multiple characters and like do
multiple scenarios but he'll always be on Fallout 4 he's not
on Fallout 4 anymore after like I think after three years
three to four years he stopped playing Fallout 4 because he
started playing other games but like that is why we are on
Fallout 76 because I don't think I have I don't think I can
commit to that I don't think I can commit to That is why We
are starting with Fallout 76 I also heard Praise be to Todd
Howard But like Basically Apparently Fallout 76 Did improve
I think it's the worst part Because Fallout 76 started a
country roads thing And then the game ended up being like
Fucking garbage but it gave us country roads um anyway
apparently the game actually is a lot better now um similar
to like similar to like how cyberpunk and uh was it no man's
land no man's sky i don't remember i never played that game
no man's something sky land ocean it's one of them um
apparently an improved So it didn't even have NPCs.
Oh my gosh, you guys just didn't understand Todd's vision.
You guys were just not smart enough or high enough IQ to
like grasp his vision when it comes to like Fallout.
But apparently it improved.
So like we get to see if it did improve.
We get to see if it did actually improve, guys.
And like because a lot of new players or new players.
joining fallout 76 there's a lot of like veteran players
that are coming in to the set like coming in to help out the
newer newer babies so maybe i'll have like maybe maybe i'll
get like boosted in fallout 76 you know guys i am not afraid
to get to get carried and fallout 76 okay if any if any of
the gamers out there with the power armor would like to be
my bodyguard and escort me like okay i need to be like a
beautiful woman okay okay okay look it's gonna work guys
it's like how like in world of warcraft we're like people
try to be like try to be like female players in world of
warcraft and then they'll the so they can get so so they can
get like free stuff we gotta be beautiful the most beautiful
vault dweller in in the surface we gotta protect the queen
okay let's see all right sculpt wait i can sculpt it wait
cannot Wait, no I can't Lies I can't sculpt the face What
the fuck What do you mean?
I can't sculpt the face What do you mean?
Okay I did I clicked on the face Oh my god A rare Ginger
Okay, that's redheads.
Oh, oh, that's how you do it.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, okay, I got it.
Oh my god.
This is, like, so complicated.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why is this such a...
This is so complicated.
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm just gonna go default.
Fuck this.
This is...
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
wait what the fuck did i click it's like world of warcraft
back then where people players would be like female players
so that like they would don't think that they're female so
they'll be like my lady do you want me to like um do you
want me to give you some gold my lady and then like you know
but i am a lady so like it's more ethical
the original cat fishing back then uh it's like old school
runescape okay it's more it's more ethical because i'm a
lady too but i hate
the female no people still do that now i gotta be oh my god
red heads okay because they're rare and the surface people
will be like oh my god i haven't seen a redhead in a hundred
years what a rare breed okay this is good this is good i'm
sorry i apologize to all the redheads in chat but i bet you
in 200 years isn't that true though i heard that like
redheads and gingers are actually dying out like because
it's a recessive gene so like um red hair slash gingers is
actually like slowly being like like like the traits are
slowly being bred out because because it's a recessive gene
so like in 200 years it's gonna be even rare it's gonna be
like a shiny pokemon yeah it's gonna like you guys are
actually going to this exchange you're endangered right now
you're endangered species at the moment so like this is
justified We got to keep the bloodline.
We got to keep the bloodline going.
Wow, shiny ginger.
All right.
Let's see.
What other makeup?
Damage makeup.
Blush one.
Blush.
Okay.
We need.
Oh, wait.
No.
Wait.
Fuck.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
You are not having any blemishes.
You are.
Okay.
Okay, actually...
Okay, wait.
No, blush.
Okay, we gotta look like we're alive.
So I think one is the best.
Wait, I wanted one.
Yeah, what?
Give me one!
I want this so I look alive!
I want to look alive for the surface people.
I want to...
oh i need to be okay look like not gonna lie but like these
controls fucking suck oh my god oh my makeup is definitely a
rarity up on the surface world so like i need them to know i
need them to know that i got it oh yes all right nice okay
let's see um Nice.
Okay.
What's body?
All right.
Thin muscular.
Okay.
In 200 years, the muscular you are, the more attractive it
is now.
Okay, guys, you won't understand because it's still 2023.
But in 22, 23, or 2276, muscle is where it's at.
Okay.
The guys out there, not only...
do they like do they are they like oh a redhead they're like
oh my god she can lift so sorry time is non-existent for me
2020 2076 2024 the 20 2276 oh my god numbers don't work
anymore right now my brain um but like being mus muscular is
an attractive trait right now in the surface world you won't
understand because you're not in that era Alright, here we
go.
I'm done.
This is it.
This is good.
Name your character.
Real female.
There you go.
Guys, it's gonna work.
It's gonna work.
Real female, dokey.
Oh my god, that's me.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, wait, what?
What happened to me?
Where am I?
I where did I go where did I go where did I go reset reset
where did I go I can't zoom I don't know How do I...
No!
Okay.
Escape.
T.
No!
I didn't get to take a...
Oh my god.
I didn't even get to take a picture of my real female dokey.
I didn't even get to take a picture!
No!
I was gonna take such a good picture.
I don't understand!
Where's the option?
Oh, there it is.
Is it Z?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we gotta...
The mouse is, like, way too high.
Like, oh, my God.
Okay, let's find...
General subtitles on, please.
And then...
We need to figure out...
Where the fuck is the sense?
Game?
Oh, there it is.
look sensitivity okay we gotta get that shit low that shit
is way too high right now oh this is optimal set uh this is
an optimal option page uh oh my god how i don't know i think
they look like they're the similar at least they're similar
i think that's a view zero okay um i don't know i can't tell
oh no it should be field of view okay no depth of view has
to be no depth of view has to be zero okay and then that
that's almost zero and then i'll raise the current fov to 85
okay 85 seems to work all right here we go i couldn't read
properly at one point all right here we go all right okay
how do i move how do i why is my hands like this oh mock oh
okay these are my fist guys oh guys why is it it's not wsc
is it not
it's w s yeah it is why is it so difficult why why is it so
difficult to move running in place.
Oh, okay, I got it.
I got, guys, guys.
I'm figuring it out.
Guys.
Guys, okay, it's working.
Alright.
There we go.
We figured it out, guys.
Alright, we're figuring it out, guys.
Oh my god.
It just works.
Is my frames on cats?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
We're slowly figuring this out.
How do I...
Okay, there you go.
Preset.
There is nothing that tells me that I can cap my frames.
Oh my god.
All right.
We have a problem.
We might have a little problem.
All right.
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay.
Free.
I'm just not...
Okay.
we might we might have a little problem time to go into my
documents my case all right 16x the details i don't even
know what words you're talking about right now to me i can't
tell what you're trying to say okay but don't worry
everything will be fine everything will be fine guys Do not
worry.
We'll be okay.
Everything will be okay.
The texture.
Ultra detail for texture.
That should be.
16 times the details.
What does that mean?
But 16 times the details.
You don't understand.
Okay.
All right.
Oh hey.
There's the TV.
Oh, this is my vault.
Oh my god.
I have a warrant.
What are my awards?
Animal Halloween costume contest?
Guys, you don't understand.
I have the outstanding achievement award.
At Vultec, you don't understand.
Guys, I'm practically perfect.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there's my pit boy.
Alright.
16 times to detail a word look there's my pit boy all right
tab to open reclamation day it's reclamation day those
surface dwellers will not know what hit them all right i'm
perfectly healthy it seems like guys it seems like
reclamation day came in past months ago but now it's time
for me to leave the
It's my turn to reshape the world in my image.
Will you live in a dokey world?
How do I change my POV?
Should I play it?
Yeah, I should play it in first person.
Mia, I'm gonna fucking turn down the sense just a little bit
more.
It still feels...
I'm doing my part!
Oh, there it is.
okay i'm gonna play in third person just to like oh god i'm
okay it's not flat guys you see that little bump there's
something there that's hot in 2276 guys you don't understand
um because back back when in the future it's harder to get
good butts so like even a little bump is like it's like a
good thing guys okay flat butts became meta all right guys
so like any anybody that even has like a good butt like mine
you see like right here right here that little bump there
that's rare that's so rare
hello hello clausworth at last today is your reclamation day
i better you're just bursting your bolts to get out there
and of course i will reshape the world in my image i'm right
do we know anything about the world outside nothing at all
the exterior sensors were taken out of commission after that
unfortunate business with the nuclear bombs with so am i the
first having been gone so long i cannot begin to speculate
how they've transformed
Well, what about the Overseer?
It's been months.
Besides, she left this place behind to reclaim America.
Wait, am I the last one?
Where's everybody else?
Oh, it's the last one to go?
Everybody left me?
What the fuck was I scared about?
The Seals have valuable information to help you thrive out
there.
Okay Don't worry.
I got this.
I got this crutchly.
I got abandoned How could they abandon me with my fucking
nice ass and like rare ginger redhead?
Okay voice the thing is the thing is sound guy.
I don't know if this voice is like considered voice chat
voice Or like all right fuck it.
Is it I can't tell I think so.
All right.
We're going to risk it.
Here we go.
I'm so ready for the outside world.
It took me a year.
I had so much trauma and that's why I was stuck in this
vault for so long.
But this is it.
This is going to be different.
Being alone in isolation for so many years has made me
worthy of going outside.
Oh, I should take some radax and purify water.
Consume drinks to fill your...
No, there's thirst meter.
Open your pitbull, boy.
I keep saying pitbull.
Pitbull.
And your thirst meter drains over time.
Okay, armor, food, apparel.
Wait, where's my water?
I only have red axe.
Where's my water?
Did you take my water?
Or did I just drink it already?
Oh boy, I sure do love the survival mechanics.
Don't worry.
They're gonna see real female doki.
And I am going to get much so much water okay we need right
away instant packs did i drink it no
i can't believe i drank it i can't believe it wait what's
this
building supplies
Wait, why would I leave then?
Why can't I stay here forever with all of you guys, my robot
friends?
It's okay.
It's okay if I want to be in isolation.
You know?
It's okay if I never want to leave the nest.
What's this?
Join a team.
Open emotes.
G.
Open.
Ooh.
G.
Yeah!
It's okay.
I'll just keep sending all the people.
this emote and they'll understand all right if you're a
dragoon you guys have to come up to me and use this emote
and then i'll be like yeah all right this is a dragoon emote
okay guys this one right here is the dragoon emote just so
you guys know and you guys didn't know that what's this
okay let's see what is this build a camp after you leave and
press z once you're in the wilderness okay is there like any
extra items still anywhere oh wait what the fuck is this oh
i can have glasses and a pet get a job Thank you for staying
with Vault Tech.
I gotta...
Okay, guys, guys.
We gotta look smart, okay?
We gotta look smart.
Where the fuck is it?
Party hat.
Wait, where's the...
Oh, there you go.
Party hat.
Okay, no, actually...
No, that looks a little stupid.
I can't let the surface dwellers know I'm blind.
I can't let them know.
That shows weakness, guys.
We can't let them know that we're blind.
chat it shows a weakness they'll be like what the fuck is
the surface dwellers will be like we kill off all the people
that show blindness so we have to so we can be sure that the
population is healthy with strong eyes like they can't
afford to it's it's so hard to find glasses guys in the
surface well we don't have machines to make glasses anymore
Weak if I have glasses on!
Oh, this is the overseer mission.
Okay, here you go.
Weakness is a sin!
Okay, Vault Tech Report.
Terminals can hold press R to reject or... Oh, wait, but I
want to read this.
29 years after the vault door closes, you're to prepare your
citizens to leave Vault 76 and be in the process called
reclamation.
Specifics will be disestimated.
automatically as that time approaches after reclamation day
you're personally ordered to find and secure three nuclear
silos codename alpha bravo and charlie if these sites are
still nuclear capable ensure no one except vault tech can
access our launch nuclear ordinance to be cleared even there
are other authorities whether government or otherwise
they're what they're what they're what
Okay, what's the holotape?
Because whoever is listening to this had the moxie to try to
find out where I've gone.
But I'm glad you did.
Truth is, I need your help.
I've been given a task and...
I've decided to break protocol and tell you what it is.
Because if there's one thing I've learned in these past few
years...
She broke protocol!
We need to rely on each other.
Okay,
but like I can't be the only one doing this like I came in
here to one or two years late gonna fuck it for us and you
six come out But it's been 25 years.
I just don't know what we're gonna my directive was to go to
the nearest population center and assess the situation I'll
set up a camp on the way once I get my bearings find me
there we need subtitles guys i turn on subtitles it is not
my fault that there were a lot of issue in this game release
guys if if by two plus 2018 if by six years they still have
not added subset subtitles for that for the fucking tutorial
for that part that is not my
It's general sub- did I not turn it on?
I thought I turned general subtitles on.
Okay, let's try it.
Let's see.
I swear to God I turned it on, chat.
There's no fucking way I didn't turn it on.
There's so many fucking...
Okay, display.
Subtitles.
Where the fuck is the subtitles?
There you go.
See?
On, on, on.
I told you guys.
It is not my fault.
I told you all I had had it all
it is not my fault that by in six years they did not provide
you the subtitles I did my job okay we turned down sound
effects a little bit and then uh effects okay we'll turn on
turn down And then we'll turn up the volume.
There we go.
I hope it's okay now.
Alright.
Sometimes it just works.
Guys.
Sometimes it just works, guys.
You guys just didn't try hard enough.
Okay.
Let's see.
What's this projector?
Oh, this is like pit boy stuff.
Alright, it's time to leave.
You mom possess the skills necessary to accomplish anything.
Again, guys, I just didn't buy the...
What was it?
Fallout 1st or whatever?
Oh, this is where the slim pack.
Okay.
Open the door.
I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready to go out in the surface world and
recolonize the world.
Guys.
Andreas, thank you for the file.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
This is it.
Real female dokey is here.
Arrived.
I'm ready.
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just letting you know there is a roleplay community for this
game.
Oh, no.
Fresh dweller.
Battle ready dwellers leave the vault at level 20 with a
special loader of their choice.
Does this mean I have to pay?
Okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, which is better?
Fresh dweller?
or battle ready fresh dweller leave the vault at level 2
with a perk of their choice they require training before
taking on more difficult challenges okay I'm gonna get fresh
dweller alright pick 20 people say it's more fun to be a
fresh dweller okay action dweller inspiration grant 5 when
you team up with other vault start with a slugger perk card
plus 20% damage grants 15% action point regeneration
gunslinger oh my god I could be a support player guys guys
if I get adopted by a surface dweller with with like a power
armor I could be like don't worry sir I got you
No.
Mercy all over again.
No, don't be in mercy.
Okay.
Okay, we'll go for gun slingers.
All right.
I want to...
Wait, actually, what are the perks?
I didn't even look at the actual perks.
Okay, agility.
My luck is one.
That sounds like me.
Okay.
Oh yeah, never mind.
We should definitely not be first aid.
We have like intelligence too.
That doesn't sound right.
That does not sound like me.
Alright, gun slinger is only guns.
Yeah!
That's right!
I wanna be a gun slinger.
I just remember guns are very rare.
But it's okay.
We'll make it work.
Hello, select help from the oh my god Wait, how did you know
out of every one now give me shit?
I'm a real female Oh my god, they got the gamble correct Oh
my god, how did What
I'm fucking rich
Oh shit I can't believe they got the RNG Wait no I was too
busy looking at it Give me give me
Wait did they give it to me I couldn't tell Okay wait I
think they did right I couldn't tell Too busy looking Did
they I have it?
Give me more.
Okay.
How do I accept it?
How do I...
Oh, is this everything?
I want all your items.
Okay.
Combat knife.
All right.
Here you go.
Everything.
I'll let you keep your glasses.
Don't worry, I'll let you keep your glasses and your party
hat.
You get your glasses and your party hat.
Give me everything else.
Guys, I need all of this.
They have soap.
God, MMOs are so easy.
Okay, how do I click yet?
How do I accept all of this?
How is this a man gonna survive?
Okay, how do I accept all of this, guys?
You want this?
I'll request this right now.
You don't.
What?
Wait, did I get it?
No, you still have your items.
I worked so hard.
Give me.
Okay, oh my God.
I wish there was an easier way I wish I wish there was an
easier way to take all of his belonging No, they they how
could you cancel?
How could you cancel?
It worked so hard.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you would do such a thing.
I literally I let you keep your glasses and your party hat
and you still cancel on me.
I can't believe you would do such a thing.
at least get rid of it I let them keep the hat and the
glasses guys tell him drop your bag no because I want the
items that he has on like I want to take everything he has
except for the party hat and the except for the party hat
and the glasses okay there you go it's not okay to cancel
What?
You bitch!
I went so high pressing space.
Empty your pockets right now.
No, it's not random.
It's not a random because... Oh, nice.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, keep going.
Okay.
Keep going
Yes, take it all off Take everything off except for your
glasses and your hat No, no, keep your glasses and hat on
That's all I ask
You can keep your glasses and hat on Reverse Oh!
Sorry, I'm done playing with you.
He has more items.
Oh my god.
You know he's a gamer because he has a different item on.
He has different clothes on.
Chivalry's strong and dragon.
you're lucky i'm being very generous and like i'm only uh
i'm only asking for like just a little bit of your stuff
just a little
bro doki how am i even i look they offer guys guys they
offer it for a real female doki okay guys it's not my fault
they oh my god he has so many items i'm so I'm gonna be
so...
Oh my god, I have to keep scrolling!
Okay.
What do I do after I requested stuff?
I'm just going to request random things.
What do I do?
Yeah, it's not robbery if they're willing to give it to me.
Do I just press T?
No!
I want everything.
Give me, okay.
Oh my god.
I want everything.
I'm just, okay, press T after.
Okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna like randomly.
Okay, I'm just gonna, oh my god, there's so many things.
I'm just gonna randomly request stuff right now, right here.
And then, all right, here we go.
Oh my god, he literally gave me his life savings, guys.
Oh my god, 52 runaways?
Oh my god, he gave me his life savings.
And then...
Show uh...
Okay, what do I do?
How do I take it?
And then what do I do?
How do I... How do I take their things?
Alright, I'll give you my glasses.
There you go.
I would like this much... I would like all of this box.
AutoCAP for this.
Plus that.
Is that good?
Fair trade.
Is this fair?
Is this...
What a deal!
Oh my.
guys can she trade at that level it's not stealing it's so
fair guys this is not stealing except all right oh that's
how you do it oh my god is that it except oh my god got it
oh i bought this stuff oh i get it i get it now i'll take
your pie okay and then and then um okay they you're giving
me their rat away and then how dare you request my
antibiotics how fucking dare
if you want my ad time throw your stuff on the ground right
now
all right guys okay why don't we be a team guys guys we're
gonna be a team invite to the team invite to team all right
you guys are gonna protect me level 52 and my level 53 you
guys will protect me all right Oh my god, I have a group!
Join my team.
Are you in my team now?
All right, throw your items on the ground.
Drop the items.
It's just easier.
Wait.
Why aren't you in my group?
Join my group.
Can I only have one person in the group?
Can you only have one person in a group?
is that true i'm sorry he's level 53
you get four join
oh he left the team oh my god i'm sorry why can't he Join my
team.
Why can't...
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Join.
Don't worry, level three.
After Mr. Elite joins, then we'll be fine.
You should...
Why aren't you joining?
He doesn't want to.
Why don't you want to join my team?
We're Team Dokeybird.
Real female.
All right, you guys can just tag along.
then.
Alright, guys.
Okay, come with me.
They're done.
I can't...
Bro!
He's just like, I can't believe it.
I got ditched so fast.
I can't even believe it.
He's sitting there.
It's like, I can't believe it.
He's so done already.
exceedingly alive it's okay guys they haven't yet made any
untoward advances but perhaps you could speak to them verify
their intentions are civil okay he declared my invite yeah
have you seen the overseer but it's been some time also i
brought the volume overall sound guy i'm sure she's all
right All right.
So what's been going on out there?
It's been exceedingly peaceful.
I maintained my post.
I believe it.
Bro's not gonna carry me.
And otherwise reveled in Appalachia's natural splendor.
But very recently, it seems people have come back to
Appalachia.
Those two and more to boot.
The non-vault sort you understand.
The non-vault?
Oh, I bet you elites the non-vault place.
I bet you he doesn't see he seems like a surface dweller
rejecting my invite only that they appear to have some
vested interest in accessing the vault one seemed quite
perturbed when I told them that wouldn't be happening but
I'm not sure if she believed me all right I hope you mom it
on my way all right guys let's go I can't believe you
rejected my Alright, you know what?
You know who wouldn't?
The person that was there in the very beginning
They didn't reject my friend request
How dare you How fucking dare you Anyway, let's actually
play this game Oh, donation box Hey there Oh, I want a
donation.
What's this?
Okay.
I'll need this.
I'll need that.
Guys, donate to the poor.
I'm poor.
Who are you?
Are you a surface weather?
Are you a surface?
Surfacey?
Surfy?
Is the door still open?
Door's still tight.
No one's getting in.
God damn it Oh dad I'm poor So this guy told us that After
you gave him the last of our caps He said He declined my
team invite too The last chance to turn our lousy luck
around Oh my god the level 3 Turned down my team invite
wait the big one what are you talking about the thing that
brought everyone back the treasure the treasure there's a
treasure here yeah there was this big broadcast but
permission to join you i'm super high level trust oh boy i
think you was suggesting thank you but those were the last
of our caps no someone has to know something we're just
gonna stick it out until we find them wonderful what's the
treasure for us i suppose this is what happens when we take
people for granadogi i look me guys is this like
no is this the one day i learned my lesson You won't have a
spare weapon, would you?
Yeah, I don't have a weapon.
None at all.
Wait, what else can you tell?
Oh, I got machete!
What else can you tell me about the treasure?
There's consequences of my own action?
We don't know what.
We don't know where.
With people as desperate as they are.
It's meant everyone with the functioning radios come back to
try and see if they can get a piece of it Monsters or no Guy
we met at the wayward What the fuck?
If you're gonna talk be immersive Okay, so what is the world
like out there?
Oh my god, you're from Virginia?
Where am I?
What state am I in?
The voices you hear the voices?
I mean, Appalachia's dangerous.
Really dangerous.
But it's better than where we've been.
Alright.
I better be going.
I found out you're from Virginia.
I have to leave now.
Oh my God!
That seems like enough I can take.
Look at all these kind donations!
Oh my God, everybody!
Everybody's so kind to donate!
The random strangers that donated to me thank you i have a
gun now look pew pew
west virginia we're a monster is that a monster shoot shoot
him go mr elite go yeah oh there's our ghouls go go go go oh
my god jazz my Army is growing!
Oh, no.
Guys, it's okay.
Overcome or running will drain AP.
What's AP?
Is that AP?
Is stamina?
Oh, is stamina?
I'm a summoner class.
Visit the wayward.
Okay, where do we go?
Okay, we're gonna visit the wayward, guys.
Okay.
How do I pin it?
Place marker right here.
There you go.
Okay.
Where the fuck is my compass?
I'm like...
No, I'm heading the right way.
Anyway.
My mage.
Go!
My...
It's like Pokemon.
I'm like the Pokemon trainer.
Guys, I don't understand.
MMOs are so easy.
Oh, I see it.
It's the bottom.
I see it.
Sorry.
Gamers don't look down either.
Oh my god.
The Doki Bird Fallout 76 experience.
Bro is playing power.
Oh my god.
Look at all these things I found.
Oh!
Is this like I can have a mask on.
I can have a uniform.
I can have an umbrella hat.
Okay.
I'm going to have like this.
And then I'm going to.
Okay, I'm going to have this clothes on because I can and
then there you go guys look I'm not gonna have that Okay Oh
my god, he has a battle armor Holy shit Oh my god
too can i be in the battle armor can i can i go inside where
did it go the power armor holy he's jumping so high bro what
the fuck he's disappeared oh my god bro guys i caught a
level guys I caught a level 255 Pokemon
guys look at that oh my god guys I have so many Pokemon
oh my god this game is already so good wait I went the wrong
way it's like no that's people I have to go to the house,
right?
She got a master ball at the start.
My Pokemans!
Because I knew being a real female.
Doki was the trick.
I knew it.
They saw the rare redhead.
I turned down the music a little bit.
And then...
Alright.
Wait, are they killing that deer in front of me?
I think...
Okay.
music low a little bit effects a little bit higher okay all
right we should be good i think what did you do was that
deer oh my god okay we gotta go this way e east for east i
think that's it yeah all right guys let's go i'm pretty the
dokey mons guys where's your house guys wait where's level
255 Where's the level 255 kid?
I wanted that.
Where's your house?
Where did he go?
He left?
Guys, I had to release him like Butterfree.
Guys, we had a Butterfree moment there.
And we had to release him into the wild to be with his
people.
No, not Butterfree.
the corpse the public team leader how does like why is he
that special why is he so special that he actually just
shows up i like your hat thank you i found it see him in 20
plus years look we had a very emotional moment there oh wait
i could join this team
Carry me.
Wait, no, that's not...
No, not you.
No, I can't!
Wally walnut!
No!
You have to...
No, Joki, you have to buy things from the Adam store.
Todd's son is going to die.
I'm going to starve to death.
Thank you for the super chat, Trish.
Thank you.
Oh my god, not Todd's son.
why do i need that when when i have my dokey mans to help me
that's okay the dokey mans will be here guys i'm like
encumbered i like how you guys are like dokey just throw
away your items i'm no i'm a hoarder wait okay i need
somebody my dokey mans dokey mans i need somebody to carry
my stuff okay All right, I'm gonna drop some stuff and you
guys gotta carry it for me.
All right, guys Okay, I'm gonna drop okay, wait how do I
drop oh drop all right guys I need you guys to carry this
All right Okay, okay, okay, jazz all right my dokey mans
carry I don't know why I have a cannonball, but Carry the
cannonball Am I am I still in cumbered?
Okay, carry my cannonballs, guys.
Are you guys shooting me?
Oh, this is it.
Guys, I need you guys to carry my cannonball.
It's right here.
Okay.
Is this it?
Oh, is this your house?
Is this our house?
Oh, no.
This is my house.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
No.
Wait.
No, it's not.
Whose house is this?
Is this mine?
This is mine, right?
Oh, I, okay, I need to get rid of.
Wait, okay.
Oh, my God, the Brotherhood office suit?
Oh.
All right, I can put my stuff down here.
All right, we're going to put away...
We're going to put away this, because I feel conflicted.
When I had that on, I felt it was a bit wrong.
Okay, we're going to put this in here.
Oh, my God, a fusion core.
What am I going to do with a fusion core?
Oh my god, there's Salisbury steak.
Oh, okay, I'm going to put this away.
And then, no, we have so many good items.
We can't store all of them away.
Oh my god, okay, we're going to put away the glasses.
We're going to put away...
Oh, but this one has a heart, so it's better.
And then we're going to put away the concrete because we
definitely don't need the concrete.
guys it's good okay let's see uh weapons armor wait i want
to wear the brotherhood officer suit oh nice okay guys do i
look good guys oh cores are for battle i don't have a battle
oh is this mine is this mine join the public team i'll join
your team where who seemed to that who seemed who are these
other random people
who are the what the fuck oh my god i got adopted guys i got
adopted my new my new lady oh my god do you want to join Are
you?
Oh my god, hey.
Are you a dragon?
What is it?
Oh, I'll join your team
Hello, oh Stimpak my god guys Look at my pottocky mans
My dokeymans!
That's so stupid.
How did I have, like, more stuff?
Guys, I need to throw away stuff.
I'm still in Coombreed right now.
Give me a sec.
I keep throwing away things and end up getting more.
Like, how is this possible?
Oh!
Mine!
Wait, no.
Not mine?
No!
I put a fusion core in there!
there.
Somebody take my fusion core out.
I'm too low level.
Somebody.
Somebody take my fusion core out.
Oh!
Mine?
Am I?
Am I going inside?
I'm just like you guys I look so good guys look at me look
at me
it's my thing my can I move in this I look so cool guys oh
my god I look so fucking cool just like them
Why is what why is it beeping though?
Is it because like I have I'm no core guys?
Can someone put a core in me?
Someone put a fusion core in here?
Oh, is it right here?
Oh nice
Guys, I'm so cool now.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking cool I can't believe this game would actually
be hard Holy shit look there's cows.
I can miss Milk the cow?
Guys!
Oh my god, wait, I gotta milk the cow.
You can milk the cows!
Oh my god, the mutant cows!
Why is it?
It's because there's radiation!
Snake!
No, none of this in this world is perfectly okay!
They don't even have fur!
The first thing you say is why does it have two heads why
does it not have fur can i shoot it guys can i kill the cows
kill the cows dokey mans kill this one cow
yes wait not all of them guys not all the cows Oh my god.
Who's Bessie?
Who the fuck is Bessie?
Holy shit guys don't guys.
I made a mistake guys.
I made a mistake Oh my god Bessie
Guys guys
cows don't don't kill the cows guys a private error is only
you and your teammates can be in this interiors okay make
important story choices all right okay let's actually start
the game
let's actually play the game whoa lady i will paint the
walls with you if you don't tell whoa honey you picked the
wrong time to get a drink what are you hey where the hell
are you I'm me.
I'm I'm real female dokey I'm the last thing you're ever
wait.
What's going on here first?
None of your damn business what's going on is that this one
seems to think I know where this big treasure is Oh, they're
talking about the treasure Lady this is your last warning
our crew is getting that treasure and I will happily send
you both to the great goddamn beyond if you don't start
explaining where I can find what's ours Are you suit
yourself?
Tell me about this treasure.
Maybe you can work something out Treasures are cruise
business not yours and unless I start getting answers right
now I'm gonna start shooting people you don't want to do
that tell him just tell him what he knows so we can suit
yourself I'll make it quick.
I have a gun Wait, there's more than one person it's okay.
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry now I'm hoping you're that's fucking right you
didn't expect me to have a gun also i accidentally shot her
but it's okay well not exactly the introduction to the way
thank god you don't miss say about that darling first rounds
on me names duchess there's something i could do for you oh
so what was that about your guess is as good as mine
sweetheart he busted in here saying i needed to turn over
the location of some fellow named crane who i guess i must
have served at some point or another since then a steady
stream of miscreants has been making my life irritating not
exactly good for a budding business so anyways she's
starting in blasting so um looking for the overseer have you
seen her overseer huh so you must be the one yeah it's me
i'm the special ginger and i understand why canada went
heavy on her cut thanks thank you the super chat thank you
thank you you's a bit out of date now maybe you're the one
she left it for i'm happy yeah only me because i'm special
we've drifted naturally onto the topic of helping one
another maybe there's something you could do for me in
return what do you want and you'll give me the overseer's
statement exchange for what exactly just agreeing to lend us
a hand and a little diplomatic intervention see that boy you
put down he's not the first of his crew to roll in here oh
yeah I have my own crew normally I'd send my people out to
clean house but my muscles run off so I don't have the
bodies to spare right now don't worry I have a lot of bodies
to spare
alright I'll help you i don't even need to know what you
need help with i have the dokeymans the dokeymans so the
details yeah now each of these boys came in asking after
crane i'm thinking we can make that work for us how would
you grab the attention of a bunch of single-minded thugs all
right meditation maybe that's what my mom did for my
birthday party though i guess no one came oh my god i'm a
loser you want me to pretend to be crane that's always got
people my time just say what you want okay you want me
pretend to be oh i have intelligence 2 plus well aren't you
i am i'm so smart i think i know just how to do it just give
me one second my level 255 walley walnut is like i got a
master ball and i caught a level like A level 50 legendary
while I'm, like, level, while I just got out of Palatown.
Architecture ain't exactly my forte.
Huh, not half bad.
So I'm smart.
Together here for you is the schematic for one custom-made
crane treasure hunting ink sign.
Ooh.
If I didn't butcher the plans too bad, it's got a little
system built in that'll make sending out an advertisement
and getting this gang's attention, a sign.
snap you just need to build it use the tape it spits out to
tell the world you're open for business and then convince
any punks that show up to tell you where their boss is
hiding they did teach you all how to build from schematics
up in that vault of yours yeah i think they did they did and
even if they didn't don't worry someone must someone in my
army knows it's called outsourcing it's I'm not here to get
my hands dirty.
I'm here to delegate.
I know they build structures.
I can do that.
Mike, thank you for the gift of shit.
Thank you.
What are you on about, Mordecai?
Hey, nah, I'm not bragging or anything.
He's a ghoul.
I've got some tapes that cover that very subject.
Oh, Morde.
Not the tapes.
Well, you find yourself wanting a refresher?
Talk to Mordecai.
Alright, I'll talk to him.
materials but we should have enough line around to cover you
there get you together a little care pack throw some rations
in there too so you don't wait am i hungry right now i
haven't eaten anything yet you might have to break some of
this scrap down for parts but i can spot you some workbench
materials too since you're doing bonus intelligence who
knows maybe you'll learn something while you
let's do this dog be good to have those adults off our back
at long last all right i'm pretty sure i can get rid of them
in like one second wait can i like just send my people out
to like do it now while i'm in this conversation oh money i
have money glad to hear vault tech actually took care of
some of their people yeah rumors right about them just
throwing folks to the wolves rations and a fancy suit good
luck well don't you worry that smooth little face of yours
you are in good company now because around here we look
after one another now what can i do for you what do you have
yes what happened oh my god can i be that rude you look like
what happened to you yeah what learn the hard way I can't
stand within 10 feet of a strawberry come on man that's a
joke truth is I was outside on doomsday now you see outside
and I was coming back from a pickup in the truck when I feel
this rumble and then quiet then a whole lot less quiet and
the truck was hit with this wind it was like someone dropped
a hurricane on it I can hear it battering in the truck bang
bang bang like it's got a grudge against it and then I
unlocked the door and into the back and then bang i wake up
man and it's crazy somehow in the back of the truck alive
and kicking what the fuck how opportunity for someone liking
me for anything other than my lovely personality and that
was the day i became well they call us schools not the most
flattering name but still beats being vaporized oh my god
that's crazy that he survived that listen friend you happen
to be talking to the exact right person i don't know what i
clicked but if i'm gonna help you i want something in return
you want and what's that listen i got this plan you're gonna
help me get rich see the folks who made it big off the gold
rush they weren't the prospectors they were the folks that
sold them their shovels now i don't do shovels what i
collect is knowledge i can go all sorts of places you folks
with your rad sucking skin can't so I'm selling what I've
got between my ear holes and you're gonna test it for me I
made these hollow tips now this sets all the info I dug up
about that camp to hickie you bolters got all I'm asking is
you give them a listen and let me know what you think okay
try listen to them I'll do the thing I mean hmm just come
back once you've taken him out for a test drive okay now
there anything else you wanted to chat about uh what's it
like being a ghoul i mean it's got its advantages main one
is that radiation rolls off me like water off a duck's ass
can stride through a blast zone like it's a spring breeze
also means i can survive in situations that would turn a
normal person into a oh my god guys i got a mixtape downside
well shit you're looking at it right head to toe disfigure
There's also, well, you might have seen them.
Not all goals are saved.
Yeah, the fair ones that I killed.
Why some goals lose their minds and others don't.
But ever since that turn, there's always this nagging
feeling just at the back of my mind that I will have to
feast on humans, Root.
Seriously?
Nothing?
Shit, I thought it was funny.
Overall, though, I thought it was funny.
I can't say I'd recommend it as a lifestyle choice.
okay so what's your job here anyway don't have one i'm an
independent oh he's he's a mooch not like me though guys i'm
a leader right they don't bother me anymore in exchange
duchess lets me drink doesn't bother me too much about my
tab really about the best sort of set up a guy in my
situation no not like me i'm a leader it's me and my dokey
mounds okay some other time then i'm the ceo all right oh
they gave me a gun too and some corn all right we're gonna
have to hunt her for hire all right guys it's time to kill
we need to listen to the overseer's log camp how do i listen
to that log it's in data listen to the overseer's log radio
oh there
this isn't a pirate radio all
right let's let's listen to the music while we're here uh is
it any items where the fuck is the misk oh look okay
overseers log south of vault 76 i knew this wasn't going to
be the appalachia i remembered but mutated animals haywire
bots What do you mean?
There's people right here.
What do
you mean?
They seem so nice.
Vault Tech was prepared.
You see this?
The cooking station, the stash box, the workbenches all
built with the camp.
You need a home base out there.
The construction and assembly mobile platform is designed to
give you one.
Just add resources,
There was no NPCs before it.
There was no NPCs?
You guys just didn't understand Todd's vision.
That's what people hated the most about MMOs.
There was no NPCs.
Like, I mean, there was too many NPCs.
There was too many NPCs and MMOs.
So Todd knew what we wanted.
But after seeing Appalachia for myself.
It just works.
The president of 76 has a safe haven they can start from.
Alright.
I always feel like she stopped talking, and then she kept
going.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, let me...
Apparently, there's, like, copyrighted music, so I'll go
with classical.
There's never any copyrighted classical music.
Alright, we gotta go kill a camp.
When you set up a camp, camp okay i want oh i'm level three
now guys look i don't know how i leveled up but look hello
everybody oh my what the fuck is speech speech speech hello
everybody level 380 oh my god oh my god okay there's i don't
have pv I don't PvP on.
I'm safe.
All right.
I'll give a speech, guys.
I'm going to give a speech, everybody.
Welcome to the team.
Welcome to the Dokiman's team, everyone.
I am very happy that to have all of you here as my...
Oh, my God!
Good job, everybody.
Now it's time to do a mission.
There's no I in team, but everybody remembered that I get
all 99% of the credit.
No, you know what?
No, I get 100% of the credit, just like my Oshi Thomas
Edison.
Because even, just remember, you're all doing this under the
name of Doki Bird.
So everything you do has the honor of taking, of having the
crew.
taken by me dokeeper because that is an honor
okay no we're not we don't need to visit the atomic shop we
literally have an army okay where the fuck is he wait what
did my game crash what happened oh my god that was scary
where's he where's the hunter for hire read the skin ask me
in my inventory okay guys i need to read the schematics guys
give me a sec okay aid miss where the fuck is the schematic
what is it called oh notes uh oh there it is learn a recipe
a craft am i okay i'm okay still all right build a weapons
work base at your camp guys who has the best house level 847
show me oh show me your house show me your house lost bud
show house
I need to know where you live show us where you live what
the fuck is that all right where do you live it has to be
close right all right we want to know where you live we're
gonna crash your place
all right we're gonna see where he lives guys guys he's
level 847 clearly his house is pretty Looking sweet, guys.
We're gonna crash at his plate.
Wait, there's a level 1000?
Holy shit.
Okay, we're gonna go to your house next.
If your house is not as good as the level 1000, guys, I'm
in...
Okay, guys.
Dokimans.
I need you guys to carry my stuff.
I have too many things.
Okay.
Dokimans, give me a sec.
I need you guys to carry my things.
Where's my backpack?
Okay, Tokimons.
I'm gonna throw away a bunch of stuff.
You guys have to carry stuff for me.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get rid.
I'm gonna get rid of some stuff.
Okay, Tokimons.
And I need you guys to carry this for me.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
I need you guys to carry all of this for me.
Okay, guys.
stuff all right somebody somebody be my backpack right now
i have like an actual i have like an army of backpacks okay
i have too many guns okay oh wait let's see i need i want to
use the pipe this one the pipe ball was it the pipe ball
action pistol
I need somebody to carry these real fast and then somebody
carry this.
Don't use them.
Guys, this is mine.
You're my backpack, guys.
Just remember, you're my backpack.
Okay, and then, oh my god, 11x2?
We're going to get that.
And then somebody carry this for me.
And then do I...
All right, I can run now.
All right, guys, I'm good.
All right, show me house.
all right guys all right where's his house where's the guy
oh there he is okay i'm okay now all right
guys don't guys don't use my items they're my it's my
backpack guys i have unlimited backpacks now guys why is it
just my like 10 millimeter okay i need like Oh, shit, sorry.
I need to, like, fucking figure out this shortcut thing.
Let's see.
Okay, quick inventory.
Where is the?
Oh, my God.
I have some mac and cheese.
Here you go.
There you go.
And then...
Oh, my God.
Look at this gun.
Guys, don't steal my stuff.
I obtained it legally.
I obtained all of this legally, guys.
Don't fucking steal.
I want to see this man's house.
And then, like, build next to it.
Totally legal.
I'm just taking my dokeymons for a walk.
I left the music in the background for this game.
Can't believe.
How did...
Did these guys found me?
Or, like...
Like, did they just, like...
kept queuing up until they got me in the server okay shout
out to that one shout out to that one dragon that fat that
was just waiting outside the vault they took their chances
and it worked
oh my god look at all these they're creating a pathway for
me
look at this house is this your house what the fuck is going
on i got money nice are these bad people i like how like oh
that was supposed to be like enemies i wonder if there's
like actual non-dragoons here They're like, what the fuck?
Whoa, he's a salesman.
Take off that jacket.
Wait, I can't even use it.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Is this your house?
Oh, my God.
Did you?
Holy shit.
I thought this was...
This is your house?
You even have, like...
i thought this was like part of the game oh my god he even
has like what the that's crazy bro look at this man's crib
holy this guy actually designed bro he actually lives in the
server who are you oh my god he actually oh my god what the
fuck is this oh my god that's actually crazy bro he actually
lives here yeah actually because like each server is
different right like each server is different so we actually
got got into a server he has a white oh my god he even has a
mess on oh my god the difference between surviving thriving.
We don't talk about that room.
Wait, there's a, oh, that's like a secret door.
Literally nicer.
Oh my god, he has like a collection.
Holy fuck.
Okay, all I'm gonna say, oh my god, he has a basement too.
The post-apocalypse is very kind to him.
What's this?
I went to somebody's Is this his fault?
What the fuck?
Bro, bro, I've been in his man cave.
Bro built a fucking man cave because he got a wife.
Holy shit.
This man has a fucking man cave.
Holy fuck.
He's a man.
oh my god he has an autopsy what the fuck am i doing oh i
can i crapped drinks on here what he has a whole god
holy shit this is actually crazy oh my god he has like
brains a fucking a taxidermy area bro this is this is some
fucking crib what's this oh my god there's a spa what the
fuck I can't get it I'm stuck why am I stuck is it because
somebody's already in the spa oh thank god okay waiting for
response from server guys the spa guys I can't the spa broke
my game No!
Guys, somebody, give me up!
It says, Oh, oh, thank God, okay, I'm okay now.
Okay, guys, I'm living the high life.
Guys, guys, I'm living the high life now.
I'm sitting outside.
Guys, I can't believe all you said, Fallout 76 was bad.
Look at this!
This man has a fucking spa!
Todd was right.
Bro, this is bigger than your actual house, man.
Why do you have a bed outside?
Bro, is this for the homies?
Like a sleepover party for the homies?
The hot tub street.
Bro, the man cave is bigger than your actual home.
where is the gamer room oh my god this is actually crazy
there are many versions of bugs bro oh shit look at this is
more power armor what as it should be yes the oval room oh
my honestly $10.10.
This is actually a sick crib, bro.
This guy has his own vault.
He has his priorities right.
What a fucking collection.
I think the most impressive thing is that we load it into a
server that has this person's home.
Like, we...
The house is the front.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Where's the level?
A thousand?
1,000 Level a thousand is time to show your crib if it's not
as good as that means Then I would be so sad
All right level a thousand is your turn to show us your crib
is your turn To show us your crib sir.
We're ready This is this is a house tour this is like MTV
right now in fallout MTV fallout right now we're pioneering
MTV doesn't exist in 22 20 70 what the fuck I feel like that
guy's an actual real player
we're bringing back MTV Cribs but because MTV doesn't exist
in 2276 we can claim it as an original idea I feel like that
band guy is a real player I don't think he's a Dragoon I
think he's an actual wait no he is he's following us never
mind he's a real player that actually needed ammo law laws
vampire he's just here for ammo hello i have the salt rifle
ammo man he's just here
he just wants some ammo bro he just wants the ammo he's just
here for ammo he doesn't know what's going on he's following
everybody he probably just saw the crowd give this massive
assault now no it's a real player talking
all right let's see i hope this okay we're gonna i i expect
mr long lost vampire to have an insane crib i mean all i
mean saying is that Lost Bond Lost Bond fucking showed us a
fucking crib like a house and his man cave so like it's
gonna be a little embarrassing if Mr. Level 1,412 cannot
live up to it
alright how far away is your house holy shit did you build
your house in the middle of nowhere like are you a hermit
sir like no pressure by the way no fucking pressure he does
have a tall bar to be at the moment please i like how
everyone's like it's gonna be disappointing doki god temper
your expectations right now yeah all right just you wait
guys i like how wally is like not even with us anymore He's
all the way up there.
Oh my god.
Look at my Doki Mons, guys.
It truly is.
Streamer privileges.
I'm gonna make it look so fun with me playing this game.
And then you guys are gonna download the game and you're
gonna get like fucking beat up by the first level 30 or
something.
You're gonna be like a new vault dweller and then you're
gonna have PvP on and some fucking level 30 is just gonna
beat you up.
It's true.
They do move in herds.
I have a full escort.
Look at my escort guys.
First time see so many people outside of the fence.
Sounds about right.
Alright, here we go.
Instead of being bullied by the higher level They're being
bullied by the level 3 This is the life Where are we
following?
What the fuck?
I feel like there is a...
Give me ammo.
Give me assault rifle ammo.
Give me ammunition.
Lava te las manos.
What the- Ammunition?
We're so confused right now.
Wait, where's the level 1000?
You still just wants ammo, bro.
Holy shit, is this your home?
You have a fucking mansion?
what is this a gated community there's no way you can't have
this entire thing as your home there's no fucking way you
you build you build your mansion you build your house at a
golf course is he bruce way oh it's not is it where did he
go Where is his house?
Where is your house sir?
Oh my god, there's too many of us.
MTV cribs for real.
Oh no, oh no, why am I getting hit?
What is this?
Where is your home sir?
How far?
What the fuck is that?
A glowing rat stag.
Is this your home?
Oh my god, you have a tennis court?
Bro, what the fuck?
Is this actually your home, sir?
No, we have to keep going.
Okay.
We have to keep going.
God damn it.
Where is it?
It's over there.
We traveled so far.
We traveled.
What the fuck?
Holy shit Where's your home?
Is this it?
I swear Is this it?
I swear to God.
Is this actually it?
Okay, dude, I was gonna be like no way that Oh
I was going to be like, holy fuck, we traveled all the way
just to see a bunch of generators.
Oh my god, guys, I don't think we're in Kansas anymore.
We traveled so far.
His home consists of three generators.
All right, is this your home?
Is this it?
Okay, not gonna lie, bro.
I think you need to hire and decorate.
Okay, that, bro, not gonna lie, bro.
Okay, this is what I expected when I first saw a house.
wait what that got locked okay i was gonna say that i locked
it look this is definitely a home this family road trip
thank you with super chat pushing thank you thank you it
looks like a real home though i'll give you that i think you
got hit up last to help you decorate your home oh my god why
let's see I'll I'll just say I'll just say question mark
where's your shelter where's your shelter maybe maybe that's
your front where's the shelter you have a vault you have a
vault sir where is it where's your vault do you not even
have a vault oh man I just need some ammo do you not even
have a do you not have a vault he doesn't even have a vault
oh my god we're gonna bro this guy keeps asking about his
vault how do I leave the team wait how do I mute people guys
how do i how do i mute people bro this guy's still what does
this have guys i don't oh there it is there's a vault i was
gonna be like i can't believe this man doesn't even have a
vault escape social oh okay escape escape social
Where's my team?
Alright, there you go.
How do I...
Oh, mute.
Okay, there you go.
Mute.
There you go.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Alright.
Oh, he got kicked out.
I get...
What's this?
Alright.
I feel like we should have saw the level 1000 house first.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, he has like a little cafeteria.
Like, for one person.
Goodbye, ammo guy.
He has, like, a cafeteria for one person.
Alright.
Not gonna lie.
I think Lost Bod won this.
I'm sorry, man.
You might be, like, super high level.
But, like, Lost Bod had the better crib.
Not gonna lie.
Don't house, Shane.
Look, there was expectation.
There was high expectations from the last fight.
That man literally built a fucking mansion for himself with
a fucking man cave.
He is optimized.
It's not about the size.
He was busy grinding 600 more levels.
he set the bar way too high all right guys let's actually do
the mission okay where am i i'm so far from home where was
my main mission i ran so far is there fast travel in this
game oh please oh there is oh my god there is lost boss
house is my fast travel
what the fuck on level four how who the fuck just screamed i
have a where am i who screamed holy shit what the fuck
somebody got injured
all right we actually have fast travel thank fucking god
okay guys i need to figure out like don't worry oh my god
i'm so fucking strong okay i need to figure out like where
my mission was where was it hey guys i need to figure out
like where to go
God, my aim is so good.
Holy shit, look at that.
Oh, me.
Third person.
You left the dokeymons?
The dokeymons will eventually find me, guys.
All right, let me, let's see.
Where's my first mission?
Go to White Hunter.
Build a weapons workbench.
Oh, yeah, we're going to build our workbench at Bod's place.
That's our new home now.
house where was it i fast traveled to this house there you
go all right i need to build a workers workbench at your
camp to scrap items build a this is my new home now our new
home guys we live here with we are their neighbors this
we're their neighbors right here how do i build it all right
i'm gonna try and remember how to build a camp all right we
are bod's neighbors guys we're we're squatting okay how do i
build it chat ceiling house it's not stealing it's not
stealing guys is you to place your camp i can't place it how
do i place it see oh there you go there you go okay guys i
need to build right next to this person's house i need a
okay right here all right i'm your new neighbor i'm your new
neighbor sir yes what we cannot i can't oh wait okay how do
i become his neighbor you need to set a camp station how do
I wait what oh it's too close don't worry bud I'm gonna be
your new neighbor I just need to be a further away don't
worry I'm almost there no why is your radius so far How am I
gonna be your neighbor?
I just want to be your neighbor, sir.
He's got a big house.
Bro!
Where does your radius end?
Okay.
Where does it end?
Bro!
Why is your house fucking huge?
Who also built around here?
Is it because everybody else is also around you?
Am I gonna come over and ask for like sugar when I'm so far?
Bro, who lives here?
Nobody's stuff.
Oh my god, that's not fair.
I want to be his neighbor.
Bro, that's not fair!
Everybody else is, like, your neighbor!
Oh, here, here.
Okay, this is it.
Alright, my new house.
This is my new house, guys.
Alright, press V to start building.
Okay.
Or hold...
Okay, hold V.
Okay.
This is my house now.
Alright.
Okay.
this is it dude all right nice i did it
guys i did it guys i did it my new home by the look i don't
need to care about what my home looks like i can mooch off
bond's house
that's that's all that matters i can mooch off
okay z c do i have anything else i'm a platform can i build
that i guess i'll just build this this is my platform where
i give my speeches guys right here i'm gonna put i'm gonna
do my speeches right here guys this is oh my god there's so
many things okay and then it's gonna have a wall in the back
how do i put it in the back There we go.
Okay, wait, wait, guys, guys.
This is, like, really difficult, guys.
There we go.
This is where I'm gonna do my speech for it as a leader.
Alright, and then...
Oh, my God.
I can have, like, food.
This is it.
And then there's gonna be food here.
And then...
Oh, my God!
I can have a gated community!
Wait, what?
What is this?
A small generator.
oh wait i can have a gated community okay okay no one okay
we gotta have we gotta make sure there's like gates in the
front so nope okay actually nah i'm too lazy to add a gated
community it's this is my home this is my crib all right
let's see holy shit what the fuck all right and then this is
my shelf guys you guys like it i have a shelf right here and
then oh my god and then i also have a table all right if you
guys want to offer me anything you put it on my on my uh on
my leader on the on the leader floor wait what's this okay
all right nice all right i think that's good guys look look
guys this is where i'm gonna give my speeches this is the
donation table the offering table if you want to give me
anything oh my god what the fuck did i just get and
halloween candy and a hat holy shit yeah this is my donation
table now if you want to donate anything you put it on this
table what did i get just now i don't get it i got a
confederate hat a confederate uniform what does that look
like does it look bad okay no it doesn't okay Nice.
Actually, no, I don't like...
Oh, it's so dirty.
All right.
What about the hat?
Okay, let's see.
What do I look like?
Oh, I look sick as hell!
And my hair's out.
Hello.
Hello, ladies and boys.
So, she's judging people's homes while being homeless.
Look, look, I might be homeless, but, like, I have a cook.
chef okay i don't need a home i can mooch off other people's
homes why waste money on electricity bills when i can have
these people to pay for it where i can just live at their
home guys it's just that easy go ahead the fixer you have
been insulted what is this insult bot sponsored by robco
then someone is in three oh okay i just got like ai'd guys
why do i need to i'm a squad i won't say i'm a squatter i
would say i am a i am a roommate okay i am your roommate
i'm not a squatter i'm your roommate that's different that's
so different Where is my quest?
Expeditions?
Is it?
Uh.
What do I need to...
Where is the...
Where's my quest?
Uh.
Hunter for hire.
Oh, build a weapons workbench.
Okay.
Load, broadcast, and activate the connection.
Wait, do I not have a worker's workbench?
What does that look like?
Wait, what's the worker's workbench?
No.
Oh, wait.
I unlocked it for free.
What did I unlock?
Oh, I unlocked my vault.
Guys, look.
Guys.
Oh, I can't even put it down.
I was going to be like, oh my god, for free.
Oh, my god.
I was going to be like, holy shit, for free.
Okay, guys.
Where the fuck is my...
Where the fuck is my workers?
workbench oh my god guys i need the workers workbench to
unlock oh my god is that my bed guys please don't judge my
bed guys this is not my real bed oh wait this is a better
bed wait how do i scroll down for this okay control no how
do i tap down for it oh there it is this is my bed this is
my crib Where the fuck is that workbench?
Is that the workbench?
What is this?
Vendors?
Alright.
No, no, no, no.
Where the fuck is the workbench?
What the fuck?
Guys, I need to build the workbench if I wanna...
Where the fuck is the...
What the fuck?
Guys, I can't progress this if I don't have my workbench.
Oh, there you go.
Weapons workbench.
Is that it?
Right?
Okay, weapons workbench.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be it, right?
Yeah.
Completed.
Load broadcast tape.
What's the broadcast tape?
Dumb bitch you live like this.
where you meet into a radio tower okay guys we need to find
a radio tower all right where's the radio tower oh i'm
learning guys i'm learning i live on the hill my awesome
crib all right guys so here's my crib i have my vending
machine right here this is my podium where people leave
their offerings if you have any offerings leave it on this
table guys this is where where's this pipe is what the okay
all right oh that's a lot of stuff i'll be fine right with
all this things in my inventory don't worry all right guys
guys i need somebody to be my backpack guys i'm gonna start
throw wait where's my stash do i have stashes here did i did
i include a stash in my crib i don't know yes i don't i
don't know if i have a stash here okay i got building stash
guys i knew i was missing something okay stairs doors light
water resources is it resources no i can't build
make a stash box where the fuck oh there it is wait i can't
afford oh i can i was gonna say i can't afford anything
that's and this is my stash box right here guys it's right
here all right nice all right let's transfer everything uh
store all right guys i'm gonna start storing things.
Guys, I have a feeling that I think I have too many items in
my inventory.
Just a, I don't know, just a little feeling.
I don't know.
I just feel like maybe, maybe I just have too many things.
Oh, I have beer.
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna have to like start putting some stuff I have 90
of this.
Okay, that's a little bit too much.
That is a little bit.
Okay, I don't need any repair stuff because I feel like, I
feel like you guys can just repair stuff for me.
How much inventory space?
258.
Okay, this is an issue.
This is actually an issue.
I don't need stim packs.
You guys can just heal me later.
I have way too much stuff guys I have a hundred and two
rataways holy shit bro how do I have guys okay I need like
figure out like I need to figure out a way to okay we're
gonna put I have a mini okay now I know why I'm so okay guys
I have a fucking mini nuke guys for some fucking no my ammo
no what ammo was that is it this i think it's this yeah it's
the 10 um is this okay all right do i still have a lot oh my
god what can i still get rid of there's so many things is it
food guys i think it's food guys Guys, I think I just had a
lot of food.
Guys.
I realized, guys, it was the food.
Okay, we gotta find a radio tower.
Where's the radio tower?
Is that a radio's tower?
Owned by Wayward Load.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, we're gonna travel to this guy's house.
I'll pay you.
I have so much money anyway.
This random guy is just gonna have money Bro, this random
guy That owns this random house Is suddenly gonna get to
have so many people Paying him two bottle caps He's gonna,
holy shit, what the fuck Bro, you're so ugly I like how this
random guy Is just getting paid two bottle caps By like so
many different people Cause you'll be like, where the Where
the fuck did this come from?
Rude.
Oh, he's not?
What is he then?
That dog looks messed up.
That's a messed up looking dog.
Wait, how am I?
Oh, it's because I'm getting radiation.
A little bit of radiation wouldn't hurt anybody, you know?
Just a little bit.
Can't be that bad.
You can't call Pamby ugly.
Alright, it's this way.
Alright.
Guys, I just want you guys to know my experience playing
this game is definitely going to be very different from your
experience.
Just so you guys know, this will not be the same thing.
The peak fallout experience.
all right whoa oh there's another leader bro this guy's 728
why didn't i join this guy's team no way oh shit my way is
under the protection of the responders we see the responders
are here to keep you safe Oh, it's okay.
Okay.
He doesn't hurt me.
He doesn't hurt me, guys.
We're friends.
We're friends, guys.
VIP treatment.
It's my little... Guys, we're on the death clause.
Guys, let's fight a death clause.
After I do the radio, let's fight a death clause.
Oh, who's... Wait, what is he doing here?
No!
Mr. Farman!
You destroyed something!
Somebody's farmhand!
This is where I draw the line.
Where the fuck is the radio?
It's this way.
Okay.
I'm always so lost.
The compass is like literally right below me and I'm always
so lost.
Mr. Farmhand!
All right, let's load the broadcast.
Let's load it.
I'm too scared of turning PvP on because I feel like the
dragoons are gonna turn on me the moment I have PvP.
on.
I have a feeling.
Let me insert this.
Emergency management.
In case of emergency, authorized user may utilize.
Oh, that's me.
I'm emergency.
I load it?
Load.
Oh, I load the wrong one sorry wait it checked the wrong one
sorry you guys you guys weren't supposed to hear that tape
it was supposed to this one activate message uploaded
initiating broadcast calls attention all consumers new
business established yeah okay
Thank you for using the Presto Radio Connection, buddy.
Yay!
I did it!
I gotta return to my camp now.
Alright, guys.
Where's my fast travel?
Where's my house?
Okay, there you go.
Fast travel.
Oh, rename camp.
Real female.
Guys, do you think they'll believe me?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Wait, we gotta go back to the camp.
Alright, so wait to see who the sign draws in.
Wait, who's gonna draw it in?
Wait to see who the sign draws in?
What does that mean?
Oh my god, I got tinfoil hat.
Untitled poem.
A moon wood moaning road room in...
What is it?
Oh hey!
hey there you're a treasure hunter you're not crane the
hell's going on here welcome to my crib tell you anything
about the treasure he found crane found the treasure holy
where is he uh let's see what can't tell me about crane he
came to appalachia not far back hunting for the same
treasure everyone else is last time i saw he mentioned
something about an abandoned storage facility he picked up
some details on but beyond the general he didn't share now
your turn where is he he's right behind you might be i pay
the place a visit appreciate the tip not crane good luck out
here all right yeah i got money i did it is there anyone
else that draws in is it just him all right we got more
intel about the treasure is that it is there anybody else
who else is gonna draw in maximum immersion oh guys i got
tinfoil hat let's see what does it look like does it look
like i'm crazy no i'm perfectly normal everybody else is
crazy is that it is that him ukraine oh yes i was like who
the fuck is this guy so rumor is you've got information our
boss wants i do where this treasure is and he's willing
Okay, I don't think you should piss me off Now I wear your
scalper as a hat Nope Okay, I have a Okay, guys
Okay, guys
oh my god guys that was a close match oh my god that was so
close i i was so scared guys holy that was so close i
thought i was gonna die i spotted the way we would first
person to get him to give up It's a share of the holy guys
that was so scary.
I thought guys I thought I was looking gonna die guys Oh my
god, that was so close
That was so fucking close guys The good my tokey monster did
it again.
All right, let's go Let's go to this guy Two calves, that's
fine.
That's fine.
Broca sent to the Shadow Realm.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What the immersion, the muted blue flame door.
Hey, are you a real person?
Hey there.
You must be a real person.
Hey.
Hey, ready, fish.
5, 6, 9, 7, 1.
Are you a real person?
Hey.
Are you real?
Are you not part of the dokeymons?
Are you...
You must be real.
Oh, my God.
This is a real player.
Holy shit.
It's a real player.
If you are not...
If you are not a real player, give me the...
Give me...
Give me the dokeybird...
The dokeybird emote.
Oh my god, this is a real player a real person in this game.
Oh my god
He must be so confused They're just like what the fuck is
going on?
All right Okay, let's see no way really real okay i need to
figure out where that's this way okay the duchess's home is
this way the toky monster mpc confirmed okay enter alone
that's crazy there's a person that has no idea what's going
on that's in my server joy thank you but super chat thank
you thank you it's free radical i know i'm surrounded by
taking my chances to rob you i did it duchess it was so
difficult i had a little like a little delay because we were
checking out some cribs just a little was that weird i just
got you know side a sidetracked a little that's like their
headquartered at west virginia company fantastic so that's
where their boss will be you just need to Wait, wait, wait.
West Virginia lumber?
Yeah, West Virginia.
You misheard them for sure.
And that's of concern.
Why exactly?
Was wandering up that way not too far back.
The lumber company, that place was overrun with a bunch of
those big green bastards, mutants.
You've seen those Frankensteins.
If this gang was able to clean those things out of the mill,
that just, these guys might be tougher than advertised.
tougher you got any recommendations on how you'd proceed
well i wouldn't go in guns blazing unless you got some big
guns oh i have some big guns more don't you worry
oh we definitely got some big guns wouldn't be a bad idea to
check in with either of them All right.
Tell me about this family.
You'll find them at Anchor Farm if these thugs haven't
already run them off.
But if they are still there, well, they probably managed to
work something out with them.
Hey, it couldn't hurt to find out what it was.
All right.
What about the scrapper?
The stall is at Tyler County Fairground.
Guy kept claiming you knew the best way to run the mutants
out of the mill.
But, listen, I couldn't get him this, Bilhau.
Probably have a better chance he'll share what he loves.
learn with someone who still has an entire face.
Oh, he's like racist to ghouls.
Well, that's a good thing.
Because that's all I've got.
If you haven't already explored up that way, the fastest
route back would be via Vault 76 and trekking north from
there.
And take care of yourself, alright?
You're doing us a big one here.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Alright, time to kill the gang leader.
Guys, okay, and so that any location you previously visit
with fast travel.
Alright, guys!
Donkey buns we're gonna kill the gang leader we're gonna
share world record our fastest kill oh my god i'm level 5
i'm like power leveling so hard those family better behavior
they're gonna get erased my donkey buns it's time to kill
the gang leader where he at all right search for traces
Well, um, travel back to the vault is here and then optional
speak to the scrapper Kill the gang leader.
Okay, tech's house is the closest.
All right, we're gonna go to tech's house.
I have so Oh my god, it's for free too tech.
Thank you It's for free.
I don't have to actually pay for your house Thank fucking
god Bro, what the fuck?
Look at this little cottage.
Holy shit.
Look at this cottage.
They have a vault house here.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Switch power pylon.
Oh, wait.
It's like they're fucking...
It's like...
It's like the nuclear bombs never hit.
Oh my god.
Look how comfy this guy's.
He has a dog!
Look!
It's, what the fuck is a robot dog?
Oh,
he even has a dog.
That's so cute.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
Let's break into this man's house.
Where's you?
Are you the wife?
Husband?
Oh, I thought I heard someone around here.
Oh, my God.
He even has, like, a wife.
This, we're just breaking into people's homes right now.
Doggo.
Oh, it's like a work in progress.
He has nothing on...
Whoa, where are you in your white sleep, though?
Wait, where do you guys sleep on the floor?
You live like this.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Murlock steamer?
Is this food?
I don't have the skill for this.
How do I level?
Oh, level up.
Okay.
Team up, work together.
Do you have reach level?
Disable pacifist mode game settings to enable play...
your combat um all damage is ignored please yes oh this is
oh i got christine broke her neck six years ago she never
looked back he he oh i have cards okay we're gonna we're
gonna be more lucky luck is measured oh yeah luck please 40%
find extra first eight chems oh yes I like that
um let's see I don't think wait no no we don't need that
what about career isma happy camper hunger goes slower when
you're on a team with others gain 5% wait I like that all
right nice use two cards you're great yeah let's create a
high-skilled one and then maybe intelligence uh no actually
no not intelligence what about endurance i'll drink first
your chance to catch a disease from food all food sapphires
hunger by an additional oh okay wait actually i should get
less radiated wait actually no there's no way my dragons
will feed me um okay you need to equip them okay all right
we're gonna equip this we're not gonna equip that root twice
as much from harvesting fast now target limbs focus fire the
weight of all okay nice we need that no what is this a
strength right no i want to put this on okay wait we don't
need you know what we don't no why can't i equip it it's
level seven
oh my god i can't believe it all right guys it's time we're
gonna fucking go and kill the leader i'm too weak but i love
it so much of my arms We're so thick.
Why is...
Why am I too weak?
Holy fuck.
Maybe I should have got agility.
What the fuck?
I feel like I'm not starving or like being thirsty right
now.
Okay, it's this way.
Guys, we can deal with this gang.
We do not need to travel anywhere.
We are not convincing the gang leader to leave.
It's a bloodbath.
We don't need to convince anybody.
We are not turning off pacifists.
I do not trust...
Guys, despite, you know, besides having an army of
dokeymans, I 100% do not trust any of them to, like, not
stab me in the back right now.
Don't be a coward.
Bro, they were throwing in...
Nukes, what the fuck do you mean don't be a coward?
I will die so fast and you all know it Look at this one Yes,
you guys think I'll be okay guys attention citizens nuclear
strike what Please exit the area at your earliest
convenience What?
Who sent the nuke?
Oh!
Oh my god, we gotta go!
We gotta go!
I'm trying to leave!
Oh my god, where is it?
Where is that?
No!
Someone did the end!
Where is it?
Oh, we're okay.
We're safe.
They're not nuking us, guys.
We're okay.
Guys, we're okay.
We're safe, guys.
Holy fuck.
Who fucking did they send it?
Can they send nukes?
Oh my god.
Someone did the funniest.
We'll be fine.
We'll be okay.
You can send it nukes.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I can't believe somebody sent in a fucking nuke.
I told you, this is exactly why I am not turning on PvP.
This is exactly why.
Chat, I told you.
Dude, those poor level ones that just came out of the vault.
They just had to make sure.
This is where they live.
I think this is where they live, right?
This is it.
It used to live.
live here.
What the fuck?
Okay, guys, these people used to live here.
You get an achievement.
Oh my god.
Alright guys, here we go.
I believe in all of you.
Can I get stuck here?
I discovered it.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm here to talk to God delivery.
Lots of it.
All right, guys, let's start.
Let's go.
It's time.
Go, Madokimans!
Go!
Is the nuke still there?
Tune into the...
Okay, I need to tune into this radio.
Oh, I can't.
I can't tune it in.
Did I do it?
Where's the leader?
Guys, where's the gang leader?
Right here?
All right, guys, it's time.
Guys, it's time.
It's time, guys.
We're gonna start the mission.
All right, here you go.
I have to enter solo!
Okay, here we go.
I can do this, guys.
I can do this.
Hello?
hello my i i didn't i didn't calculate not having my
docimons here i did not calculate for this
whoa what the fuck oh shit guys i didn't calculate for this
nuke outside?
Guys, I think that was the...
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
Guys, guys, I need a heal.
I need a heal.
Guys, I think that was the nuke outside.
Yeah.
Wait, I want to see.
Guys, I'm going to go back.
I want to see the nuke.
What is...
I missed it!
No!
I want to see!
Where's the nuke?
Guys, I didn't finish the mission, but I want to see the
nuke.
Oh, there.
Wait, where is it?
Is it gone?
Guys, where's the nuke?
No!
I missed it!
Guys, send another, guys.
But, like, don't send it here.
But, like, oh, it's right here.
The blast zone.
Wait.
let's wait actually okay wait wait wait I want to check it
out no I missed it is it still going on guys that's that way
how long is the cool down what how long
does the cool down no
Guys, send another one!
It'll be so funny!
Where the fuck is the gang leader?
I was too busy doing this mission!
Just say...
I lost the cooldown, guys!
This is important.
Oh, hey.
I can sell that.
Is that it?
Where's the fuck is the gang leader?
Oh, it's down.
here okay oh you have to go downstairs no one's heard from
better suspect he finally managed to get himself killed
better than a long shot anyway always figured it takes
someone coloring with a full box of crayons to find us our
prize we talk almost shot him they're running a parade
through here now you want to tell me who the hell you are
and what you want two hours I want you to leave I want to oh
I want you to leave the wayward alone and why exactly would
I do that um because you'll be dead sure we will kiddo yeah
oh shit that's fucking right you should have listened to me
that's fucking right I told you I told you you'd be dead it
was that easy leave the king of the freemium they should
have taken me seriously I had a whole crowd of dokemon's
waiting outside that's the whole one way to do it I can't
believe it
Why are you, Wing Gun?
Exactly.
Leave the wayward alone.
That's fucking right.
Leave it alone.
You want to see the nuke chain servers?
Okay.
Alright, later.
Later.
We'll end it with seeing the nuke.
There's a boss.
Is the boss still there?
Hello, guys.
I did it, guys!
I did it!
A platform.
Give me a thumbs up, everybody.
I did it myself, guys.
I want a crowd of thumbs up.
up yeah applaud me for my good job boost my ego
hey man thank you for the five gifted shifts thank you thank
you i needed that okay apparently people are here i'm gonna
travel there
next thank you for the super chat thank you thank you but
cool that's most likely due to players crashing the servers
holy shit is this the radiated zone all right guys i'm here
to check it out i want to check out the nukes am i here
right am i heading the right way is this it is this where Oh
shit.
Oh shit.
Guys, what happens if I get full radiated?
It won't be that bad, right?
Well, I can't...
Am I gonna...
Am I gonna get something?
Guys, am I gonna grow tumors, guys?
How do I...
Okay, I need to get rad away.
How do I see it?
I need specials.
equipment.
Guys, I'll be okay, right?
Guys, guys.
Oh, I'm gonna be like the incredible hawk.
Guys.
Okay, guys, I don't have rat away because I threw it all the
way.
I didn't throw it all the way, but like I, uh, wait, no, I
do.
Oh, wait, nice.
I got rat away.
Nice.
I got it.
I'm okay now.
Guys, I'm okay now.
So how do I Go in That'd be okay I'm level 6 I'm gonna risk
it It'll be fine It'll be fine if I like Eat right away Guys
it won't be fine I won't wait it's only plus 57 Oh it won't
be fine It won't be
so radiation No
Guys It was not fine, guys.
Guys.
Guys, don't loot me, guys.
Don't loot me.
I had so much items.
Do I have my items?
Do I keep it?
Do I keep my items?
I can't tell if I keep my items.
I do.
I'm okay.
guys I'm okay hello dragons I'm okay guys see I told you I'm
I basically became a superhero I knew the radiation won't
make me stronger I knew it I knew the radiation will make me
stronger guys okay let's get some rat away does it go faster
let's see wait a hazmat wait a hazmat suit oh my god whoa
what the brotherhood god help us wait nuclear strike
imminent again oh it's here guys guys there's another one
guys let's go Another nuke!
We gotta go!
Guys, that's right.
We're gonna run over and see it.
Oh my god, where is it?
Gotta go, guys!
We gotta see it!
The blast zone!
Okay, wait.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, we gotta get in the blast zone.
Oh, put on the hazmat.
You're right.
We gotta put on the hazmat.
Armor.
Apparel.
No!
I'm not...
Guys.
Yeah, guys.
I don't think we're gonna be putting on a hazmat suit
anytime soon.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know, guys.
Oh my god.
a naked mole rat is he okay he's not good he's not a nice
naked mole rat just get to level 50 okay we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it okay wait we need a okay i need a uh
change rat away where the fuck is rat away oh there it is
all right we gotta get some rat away on am i heading the
right way oh my god this is it All right, guys, we're gonna
watch something beautiful.
All right, here we go.
I dare one dragoon to go into the blast zone.
I double dare a dragoon to go in there.
You won't lose anything anyway, right?
If you are a true dragoon, you will get blasted by the
nuclear bomb in front of me.
I like his thumbs up.
I'm down, bro.
Let's go.
Give me a thumbs up, back.
That dragon over there.
Oh, my God.
Is that it?
Is that the...
Right there?
What's that?
Oh, my God.
Goodbye, dragon.
You're a hero.
shit is he dead oh he's dead oh yeah he's definitely dead
hey there it is i just watched the man die whoa and then you
put your thumb up to see if you're you're in the bad part of
the radiation i think i'm in a good part it's beautiful like
a sunset look at that see it's not bigger than my thumb
right now.
So it means like I won't get hurt by the radiation.
Everybody's fine, right?
We're all okay.
That wasn't so bad.
See guys?
It wasn't so bad.
The radiation hasn't even hit terminal yet, guys.
See?
You can walk around it.
Wait, wait.
It is not bad.
Guys, look.
See?
It's not that bad.
Oh, oh, oh, it's getting bad, guys.
It's getting...
I just know...
Wait, okay.
Guys, I'll...
It won't be okay.
They swear by...
Someone's in the middle of it.
How did he get in the middle of the radiation?
How did you guys get here?
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh, is this the event?
Wait for the mine shaft.
Roblox Declare?
Wait, this is the event.
Right?
Welcome to the underground.
A boss event.
I'm gonna follow the OS man.
He seems like he knows what he's doing.
Hey guys.
I might be level 5, but like I'm tougher than you think.
Wait for the Mindshap Roblox.
Was it here?
We wait here?
Guys, guys, it's like Bring your kid to work day.
It's bring your kid to work day right now.
Guys, I might be level five, but I got moxie, guys.
You're in class.
It's okay.
My teammates will be here to help me.
Next, thank you, thank you, thank you.
By the way, most Fallout, I was only re-adapted for a few
weeks.
radiation for small amount is radioactive for 35 years it
gets in your food your body thinks it's calcium your bones
be oh that's so cool what has what has uh santium 90 i want
to have radiated bones but also not in a way where i can get
cancer guys look oh my god there's a level 20 here anyway
we'll be fine i'm the pokemon trainer guys i'm gonna be that
pokemon trainer We're gonna wait for this to clear out.
Death from above.
We completed it.
That's not cool, Toki.
I should get rattled.
I should take some rattled away, though.
It's okay, guys.
We had three people with power armor in front of me.
Am I the lowest level here?
We'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
I believe in us guys we'll be okay everybody we might be the
lowest level here but like I believe in my team oh I got
pickaxe I like the uh I should stop picking up items I can't
help it I see loot and I want to take it my god I love like
the the environment around this though oh all right one more
minute guys one more minute oh so no there's enough we live
we're having to our level 1000 did he leave did our level
1000 left us bro he's supposed to carry us
i can't wait i can't wait to take off guys you'll give me
all the loot right and i'll never again but like i it's the
thought that counts you know this is a rough event no he's
got what happened to my army of dragons where did you all go
where did you hurt my vampires feelings guys where did he go
Abandoned.
We lost soldiers.
Guys.
Oh.
Let's go.
Frontline, guys.
You're at the front line.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's fall damage.
Oh my god, there's fall damage, guys.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, what's this?
Oh.
there's damages go dragons go what is that earl williams
what is that oh is that the guys i don't think i'm doing any
damage guys help you're on fire you're in a power suit guys
am i helping i'm helping right
I think I'm helping.
I'm doing my part.
Turn down.
You know what?
I'll turn it on.
There's no way.
There's no way he's going to start hitting me the moment I
tab into my menu.
What the fuck?
What's going on?
What's that sound?
Why did it get scary?
Guys, protect me.
I'm going to turn on my damage numbers.
I want to know how much damage I do by how...
Okay, let's see.
Damage number.
Guys, please don't let him get near me.
I need to look at my damage numbers.
Show floating markers.
No, that's not it.
What is this?
Show damage numbers.
There we go.
All right, let's see.
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, he was screaming at us.
Okay.
Guys, I am...
Is that 1 or 11?
I'm helping Go, go, go, jaguars Go, go, go, jaguars You guys
got this Yeah I believe Yeah
Oh my god There's a level 40 Holy Holy
we'll be fine we'll be fine did we lose anybody did we lose
any dragons it's okay our level 804 don't worry my one
damage adds up if i keep shooting it'll add up eventually oh
don't worry i have so much food i stocked up on so much food
guys give back the new goodies I just need to make sure I
don't get hit, guys.
Make sure I don't get hit.
Protect the president.
It means you're number one.
Exactly.
Guys, we lost a lot of dragoons.
There's only four of us.
Oh, wait.
There's more.
Wally, Wally, that is here.
Okay, I think we lost a lot, though.
I'm pretty sure we had more.
I'm pretty sure.
I think we actually had more before.
guys i'm helping i'm helping reinforcements have arrived oh
thank god oh i actually shot the wrong one thank god there's
reinforcement no red crap we got you bro bro loss is like
tanking everything look at him go holy shit look at this man
go i don't have to throw a grenade guys i want to throw a
grenade the one that is yellow is my crit hit i know i can't
believe it from one to one holy i'm level seven boys i'm
level seven now i'm fucking gaming guys oh my god i'm doing
twos did you guys see that I'm doing twos
bro like I did twos man I'm getting better it's like when I
get like super lucky it adds up alright it adds up in the
end guys this is the best weapon I have This is literally
the best one you can't we can't get better Okay, we actually
cannot get better
This this is our weapon is the wait is the two shots
suppressed him and no I got you Did I he gone?
I got you Wally Wait, what the fuck you're just hiding?
I thought...
Alright, don't worry, we're fine.
We lost so many.
Oh, no.
I swear there used to be more of us.
I swear...
Oh, behind us!
Behind us!
Protect me!
Guys, I'm only level 7!
Protect...
No!
I said 100!
227-6!
Protect me!
I'm not...
most important one here don't worry i got you protect the
queen guys we're losing a lot of men right now don't worry
it adds up it's adds up guys don't worry i'm doing my part
i'm doing my part okay let's see i know i have grenades i
don't i okay grenades oh i have a hunting rifle wait i have
more than this guys instead of one damage i'm doing four
okay guys honestly though i think like it does not matter i
think at this point due to like damage per second this is
like the most efficient
if we look at damage per second we might as well The hunter
rifle Takes just way too long True Oh god Oh god there's so
many minions There's so many minions but don't worry I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay I think Doki is Heal it up There's no
way I'm healing him I am contributing guys I I'm
contributing as best as I could.
Okay.
I am doing my absolute damnedest right now.
Look.
Oh my god.
Imagine like how much I'm going to level up by the time this
is over.
Guys, just imagine.
Look, I am contributing.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Okay, guys, I'm gonna see if I can equip, like, a...
I have to have, like, a fucking grenade, right?
Where's my grenade?
Oh, I got sugar bombs.
Is that a grenade?
I, like, threw away all my nades to my backpacks.
What the fuck is going on?
What's this?
Oh, no, that's just heals.
Okay, I threw away my...
Guys, I accidentally, like, threw away my nades.
look for nukas okay okay i'm gonna try nukas just make sure
they don't get near me because i'm looking for stuff right
now and nukakola right away oh i actually did throw away all
of them by accident it's okay i have food though i have food
though don't worry i'm i'm helping i'm helping guys let's do
it by oh shit you know what i should like it in third person
more i feel like third person you can see it better wait we
did it we're gonna do it guys we did it oh my do we all get
it together do we each get our own set of items or like do
we share it do we all share it do we get each get our own
set of items only 510 oh we have to escape the mines oh no
oh no oh no i'm still level eight oh loot is personal that's
great oh no oh no we got to escape guys i can't believe i
can't believe i spent so long with my one damage and i just
i just get eight 800 damage.
Are you are you fucking kidding me?
No, don't let them touch me.
Don't let I got more damage.
I got more XP from the fucking Wendy goes.
That is so messed up.
That is actually that is so fucking messed up.
I actually get more.
I was there.
I got more.
I got 810 for fucking damage.
I got thousand from killing a Wendigo.
Like, what the fuck?
How do...
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I participated, guys.
Is this it?
Are we outside the mines now?
Are we good to go?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Are we outside?
I can't tell.
Alright, guys.
Good job, everybody.
I know.
I did it everybody A real challenger Oh fuck
Oh yes Oh I just I just lived in time Oh my god I'm alive
I'm like Holy shit I'm fucking I'm alive Oh my god I'm level
10 Item reward Yay Okay I think I ate too much of the rat
away I was like freaking out I was I was fucking freaking
out Just then Holy shit Oh my god there's a jet pack wait
there's jet packs in this game holy this game is like so
complicated there's like fucking turrets and everything too
what's this guy's house like what's this house like
oh he locked it i can't believe he doesn't want me in it i
don't understand You don't want the dokeybird tour on his
crib.
We did it everybody.
I'm gonna steal your fucking flower
Oh my god I got three star rolling pin.
What did I get?
Wait, all right, I knew I got the healing slot.
Oh wait, I got oh my god guys look I got a rolling pin down
Look at that
oh my god wait what's this knuckles oh that's so fucking
what hit me oh i thought actually got hit i was like did i
accidentally turn pvp on what what happened okay what else
did i get oh my god look look i got like i got a rolling pin
look at that you get bounty you pick somebody's lock all
right guys let's break into this man's house my final...
Guys, guys, somebody break into this man's house.
I request somebody break into this.
Come on, guys.
It'll be so funny.
No way.
Oh my god.
Hey, guys.
What the fuck wanted?
Oh, it's his house.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no, he broke in.
Guys, we got a wanted criminal.
I was like, oh my god.
Wait, is this like an interrogation?
Oh my god.
He is wanted.
Guys, it's five, it's five bottom cats.
We can actually, oh, we can.
Oh my god, the five bottle caps!
Holy shit!
Man, God, for five bottle caps, holy shit.
What makes you special?
Must be...
Oh, it's like a level 25.
Oh my god, it's like a workbench.
For five bottle caps, man.
That...
Just because we broke into this man's house.
That's actually like crazy.
The betrayal.
Wasted for five bottle caps.
Holy shit.
Five caps well earned.
Nice.
Good job guys.
Good job everybody.
We fucking did it.
Five bottle caps is five bottle caps.
I love multiplayer.
This is also why I joined why I wanted to play multiplayer
because like Like you when you play fall when you play like
single player games You sort of know where it's headed, but
when you play multiplayer games You every it's an adventure.
It's a new experience All right, everybody back to my place
Back to my place everybody I need to remember I wore my
houses my house oh it's right here real female all right
here you go that dragon dying viruses what can you even get
for fast travel that's what what do you mean i should start
charging people guys don't come to my house yet i'm gonna
start charging people to to come to my house just like all
the other fast travelers i'm gonna charge it um change icon
There you go.
That's when you know it's me.
Wait, no.
Because I'm the law.
Alright.
Where the fuck's my house?
Is it here?
Oh, it's right here.
Alright.
Everybody, this is my house.
Wait, what's in my...
Ooh!
What's this?
Plan.
plan plan plan oh my god soul survivor look at all these
recipes that i earned oh my god guys guys our house is gonna
be so much better now guys okay i got some i found some new
plans guys i found guys i found some new stuff guys okay how
do i all right
Did I not unlock it yet?
Okay, we're gonna unlock a...
We're gonna put this on here, though.
Yay!
Alright, guys.
Guys, everybody.
Guys, in front of me, guys.
This is the leader platform.
Everybody, in front of me, everybody.
Stand in front.
Your leader requests you to stand in front of me.
Fancy, I know.
Alright, everybody.
As you all know, before I begin my speech, give me the
dragon, the, give me, sorry, give me the Doki, the Doki
emote right in it here.
Sorry, they both start with D's.
Dragoons, give me the, give me the Doki emote.
That's right, the Doki emote.
Nice, all right,
Dragoons.
As I say, thank you for the wonderful experience.
Uh.
Thank you for that wonderful experience.
At Fallout 76.
I had a great time.
I don't think I, like we did much of the actual lore of this
game.
I don't think we did much of the lore of this game.
But I still had a great time.
I'm honestly inspired to one day Play either New Vegas or
Fallout 4 in the future Because it has been a really fun
Time everybody Anyway To end it off I request all of you to
turn off PvP right now And the final person to live Gets to
kill me Alright When I count the
Alright Alright In three, two, one.
I just don't know what's going on.
Oh my god.
I'm killing each other.
Shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
There's so many people dying!
Oh my god!
It's
changing!
There's so much trouble.
Who's still alive?
Who's still...
I can't see anything!
Oh my god!
Fuck, I'm just gonna go into this.
I told this is my new home now.
Oh my god.
Who's still alive?
Alright, guys, I think this is gonna take forever guys.
So how do I turn off PV?
Oh my god.
I don't want to turn off PvP I started another war My PC
would have Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god He's like Oh god Oh
I can't to level 20 Oh Hey guys, JK.
Wait, settings, game.
Oh, I can.
Okay, settings.
All right, while you guys kill each other, let me figure out
how to turn on.
Settings.
Game.
Off.
All right, guys.
It's off.
14 damage.
I'm still okay.
Wait, what?
Wait, I can shoot people, but people can't shoot.
shoot me?
Oh my god, I'm fucking invincible!
I fucking knew it.
I knew I was invincible, guys.
I knew nothing can kill me.
I knew the radiation works, guys.
The radiation!
Is it because I'm next to my house?
That must be it.
No, I'm not.
see I'm I can live forever I knew it nothing can nothing can
stop me now nothing can stop me now I knew I could live for
JK guys see look at that look at that I told you guys I'm I
can live forever.
It was the rats.
I knew standing in the middle of the radiation zone would
help me.
Look at that.
Anyway, guys, GG's everybody.
We have another stream in an hour, a member stream in an
hour, so I am going to, wait, double check.
I'll double check.
Don't worry.
You guys can keep trying.
I'll double check.
Yeah, see?
I'm fine.
I can shoot other people.
Yay!
He's first dying around me, but I'm okay.
Just like Todd Howard intended.
guys just like Todd Howard wanted wait what's it what is he
doing here why is he why is this guy just who is he but can
he kill me is he the chosen one are you the oh he's the
chosen one he's the chosen one kill him before he kills
me he's the chosen one
kill the farmer all right anyway chiches everybody as always
hydrated pause to check get up and move around and get that
blood flowing and you stay up for me and you're a member
maybe stay up for another hour to watch one of the one of
the best superhero movie of all time the flash in 2020 the
flash from 2023 all right guys i'll see you guys soon
everybody bye guys